hello sorry I'm just
fiddling around with the
settings sorry I'm a bit late I had some
uh small
issues with my graphics card but
everything should be set up can everyone
hear me
okay all
right
hello hello Gabriel hello Seth hello
everyone all
right spooky sounds are
spooky people have been falling ill
after coming into contact with the Gloom
drifting through these
Caverns it seems yeah there should have
been a master mode but we're not
probably not getting that it's a bit
weird but you know it is what it
is to be fair it's like Master mode was
not like the biggest thing for me in bre
wild I don't think I ever finished
Master mode we need to be ready for but
some people like the challenge I know
I'll be okay with you link hey Sonic
solve this mystery oh Germany my
neighbor there should have been DLC yeah
I feel like they
would have had a great opportunity to uh
you know explain some things that
weren't explained very
well although I I don't even know if
they would have done
that CU you know creating a champion not
creating a champion uh Champions ballot
wasn't exactly a huge story Revelation
either uh let's
see hey thank you Kieran Kieran Buckley
will there be a Zelda release this year
uh if it is it's probably going to be a
remake or remaster or you know we can
get our hopes up for 2D Zelda game it's
been far too long but uh not sure
like 3D Zelda for sure like a new 3D
Zelda is going to be at least a few
years I
feel Wind Waker please yeah I think that
would be cool for people like I myself I
can play it on the on the Wii U anytime
I want I have both Twilight Princess HD
and Wind
Waker
zai Zone
actually do I have the oh
no I do think I have the ultra cam on
but probably not going to use it very
often I just want the link between world
REM yes that would be that would be a
pretty good idea I
feel that's the one game that that I
only played
once and you know I had to borrow it
because I I've never owned a
3DS Oracle remakes yeah Fair as well the
only thing I really disagree with is uh
Minish Cap people are like we we need a
new Minish capap REM like remake or I'm
like that that game still looks so
gorgeous if anything I think like
putting it into in the the same art
style as the or or as the uh which one
was it the links Awakening I think it's
only going to hurt the legacy of the
game just make it more available for
people I think that's
[Music]
enough
yeah the it's part of the aesthetic
besides it's the pixel art in Minish Cap
is really really good it's one of the
best looking 2D Zelda games in my
opinion oh yeah black links yeah do do
what you need to do
man say hi to your family for
me they're like who the hell is Monster
maze
die man that was close I felt like I I
was almost dead you're not hurt are you
link so I'm not going to be capturing
any footage of this opening segment
because I have plenty of footage of this
for my for my last video I had to
capture all the all things
here in this part of the
game I almost died yeah I actually
speaking of minap Jordan I saw you were
playing Minish it looked fun includ
stories of a Great War fought long ago
it was a conflict between alled I was
lurking for a few minutes before I had
to get back to
workon is it possible do these murals
dep the same
Legend the imprisoning
war demon Stone this is similar to the
statues we saw earlier a
Zoni and these figures look like
hens this depiction certainly suggests
that the zi descended from the
heavens I hope you do a Dutch language
Ral how about I just do a video about
how I don't like the story of Tears of
the kingdom and just do it in all Dutch
so so people cannot actually understand
what I'm saying or most people
can these murals tell a similar story
and if they are accurate then the gods
mentioned were the
Zone they must I'll just be like cursing
in Dutch working the
establish the kingdom of Hyrule
this figure he seems to be stealing
something of incredible power from the
young Kingdom
Perl this all aligns with what I've read
during my
studies actually I disagree I think I
don't think this story is necessarily
better than breath the wild story it's
more
complex but complexity is not
necessarily tied to whether or not a
story is good you
know there's definitely more happening
in this story and there's more like
sense of progression I guess you could
sayal must cuz in bre wild you just get
a lore dump at the beginning and it's
like well that's pretty much all that
happened and the now go grow stronger so
you can face Ganondorf or Ganon Calamity
Ganon but that's uh you know that's
me all right then now to use this
invention of Po like stories can be
simple and still be
consistent and complex complex stories
can
be too complex for their own good or
it's like the rest of the murals are
obscured but I will so I I will just be
uh up front about what I'm going to be
doing in the next few weeks is I will be
making a video like most of what I'm
playing today and doing today it's it's
all in preparation for a video where I
critique the story it's not going to be
like a hateful video where I'm just
complain for the sake of complaining or
whatever I just want to give it a fair
deconstruction and you know talk about
the stuff that didn't work for me talk
about the stuff that did work for me
because there's plenty of stuff that
does work like this for example this
whole setting this whole opening segment
is really good in my opinion I think
they nailed it with the with the
atmosphere there's not really much to
complain about that the the the F the
final fight the whole finale basically
is really really good it's one of the
best in the whole series
probably like the fight itself it's both
challenging but it's also very cinematic
you know I think people some people have
been a bit outspoken about like oh
there's too much hate towards tears of
the Kingdom like well is there though
like aside from Bandit
Jordan like most of the bigger creators
haven't really delved into the story
like not not an actual story
critique we all just continue to make
lore videos and you know obviously
there's every channel has their own main
focus and this is primarily a lore
channel so obviously I'm not going to be
holding back for
that
[Music]
damn narrow narl was brutal in his
review well I think he was
reasonable I like I didn't agree with a
lot of the stuff he said at least in
terms of
gamepl but he didn't touch upon the
story so cuz in my opinion the gam play
is
good it's it's fine it's uh it's like
breath of the wild so how can it be
wrong unless you didn't like breath the
wild then it's a different story but if
you liked breath the wild you're going
to like
this who carries that fragile sword but
I think once I put my thoughts down like
in a cohesive man Manner and I really
lay out the the the basic problems I
have with the story I think people might
be a little bit more understanding of
the other side of the of the
discussion
cuz actually I'll just let this this one
play out for a moment cuz it's quite
loud cuz I do feel like I need to
clarify a little bit about how how
people think about the game so far and
what the current trend is
and how there's plenty of s like Silver
Linings to it as well cuz people pretend
like even if even if you don't like this
game it's going to be the end of the
world it's like no there's like 20
games like one one game not resonating
with you is not going to completely ruin
the whole franchise for you at least it
shouldn't I did not like Phantom
Hourglass at
all I didn't like skywood sword when it
first came out and you know I still love
the
series I do like uh I do like it now by
the way I skyw sword has grown on
me quite a
lot still not my favorite Zelda
but I accept it for what it is and I
appreciate what it did for the series
especially in the story department just
the overall lore like if we didn't have
guy with sword we didn't know about the
the curse of the m and the origin of the
master sword and fi and you know I think
that part is very very important to the
to the lore it kind of ties it all up a
bit
more I think we're at a 75 positive 25
negative split H that I mean it depends
on in which circles you are
like obviously I'm not on Reddit because
I value my
sanity and I keep my time on Twitter at
a very healthy almost never I'm I'm just
there to promote my own videos and
retweet stuff from my creative
friends but I I I I don't really go into
discussions very often on Twitter
because I just don't see the point you
know it's a waste of
time most people on Twitter have already
made up their mind about everything
and I don't know the best way to discuss
with people is to find someone you
respect and care about see if they have
opposing
views because I've been talking to other
Zelda creators quite a bit and you know
it's uh it's refreshing to hear other
people's
takes but you're not really going to get
that from some Rando on
Twitter because you know they they I've
heard a great deal about well we we'll
get into that soon but I think both
sides of the argument are
equally rightful in their opinions
because you know if that's how you feel
that's how you feel but they're also
equally
obnoxious like both sides can be
extremely annoying to deal with I had to
replace it the injury endanger you
further oh man my
arm he's taking it well
though link is taking it very
well what are your hopes for the Zelda
movie uh just that it doesn't suck
that's about it I I have no expectations
right now I know the the the the
director the people behind
it and so far I'm
optimistic I just want to
enjoy
something and I'm pretty sure Nintendo
will keep a close eye on it if it ends
up not delivering they will pull the
plug on it there they are that type of
company that would do that anything to
protect their
IP like we're not living in the 90s
anymore we and get away with things like
the Super Mario movie or the Zelda
cartoons even though I kind of like the
Zelda cartoons they're they're they're
guilty pleasure of
mine do you prefer an original story or
retelling for the movie I think I would
prefer an original
story probably just have some familiar
like elements where we can do the
Leonardo DiCaprio Meme and just point at
the
screen but tell it in a in a different
way do you think Tom Holland will be
linked uh no I think
whoever plays link I think it's well you
you should just watch uh zeltic second
video about the the
movie CU I discussed that whole part
with
him he uh he thinks that as do I we both
think that it's going to be a bit like
Avatar not the air not air bender but
the blue aliens one like it's going to
be a lot of motion capturing and
so the characters themselves might not
even
be like actual people on
screen because if you look at the the
the director himself that's kind of what
he's been he's been vouching for that
technology and he's been doing a lot of
like I think they call it a previs like
a prev visualization of ideas and they
all coincide with that style of using
motion captures in a digital
world I don't know I just don't like the
idea of having famous actors on screen
playing characters that they probably
don't even know all that
well like if I see Tom Holland I just
see Tom Holland you know I don't see
link no matter what they do to his hair
or his outfit I'm just going to be like
oh that's Town
Holland so
beautiful this part they really killed
it with this
part let's
[Music]
go how vocal do you think they will make
link
uh I don't think they're going to be
doing the same thing as with the
games I think they he's just going to
speak maybe he'll be a bit stoic more
like the the the strong quiet type but
I'm pretty sure they're going to have to
make him
speak same with Mario Mario doesn't
really talk that much in the games as
well and he talks a lot in the
movie I wish they included more islands
like the great Sky Island yeah I agree I
agree I think they could have done a
little bit more with the island concept
especially since it was
so so prevalent in the promotional
material but you know we got the depths
in return which you know it's
something W the performance is a little
bit iffy right
now probably my graphics
card yeah oh it's Zelda Oh wait we're
not supposed to know that
yet that that part of the story they
really managed to hide that fact very
well like no nobody guessed that as far
as I'm
aware we all thought it was maybe raru
was going to be the dragon cuz he kind
of looks like he has like dragonesque
features to
him take your
stick remember when we first saw the
Zone ey charge in the gameplay
demonstration and we all lost our our
damn Minds like finally we had the word
Zone I show
up yeah I also thought it was raru I
didn't make a video about it because I I
don't know I was about to say something
clever like uh like everybody else was
doing it but I actually don't know why I
didn't make a video about
it maybe it was because other people
already did
it I don't really like to retread old
grounds if someone else already did a
great job explaining it or doing a
theory about
it the Zone I brain Rod fully set in
after I finished the
game I remember NBC going nuts when he
saw it yeah yeah yeah yeah oh great
times great
times the whole anticipation for this
game was so
fun even though it took for ages like it
it took such a long
time also because of the whole Co
situation but
yeah the sky inter tears is on par with
Skyward Sword both have stuff to do but
there's not but it's not very
interesting the surface in both games is
better yeah I I would carefully agree
with
that I do think there's a little bit
more to the sky islands in this game
than there was in skyw Sword like there
were only like three islands or
something that had anything of Interest
aside from like goddess
chests but
yeah they could have done a little bit
more I thought there was going to be
whole worlds up here like the great sky
island but it's it's kind of just the
great Sky Island plus all the smaller
stuff and the smaller stuff doesn't hold
any like big story elements aside from
maybe thunder thunder head or not
Thunderhead uh dragon head dragon head
Dragon Head
Island uh are you disappointed that we
will most likely never see tear of the
Kingdom's abilities like Ultra hand and
Ascend in future
games uh
no like whether this is a one-off or not
I'm I'm
like I don't really get attached to one
thing like for example if the next Zelda
game doesn't have climbing like spider
climbing like you can just climb
everything I'm sure I will still enjoy
it in different ways I don't really like
to
uh cuz you know that's kind of the whole
Zelda formula thing is where like once
something works they just keep reusing
it until people get tired of it I think
it's fine if every game just does
something completely
new like the the wall merging Mechanic
In A Link Between Worlds I I don't think
I would want another game that has that
because that would make Link Between
Worlds less
unique
obviously there are going to be things
that will be coming back in Future Zelda
games I don't think the paraglider is
going to go away because it's just such
an amazing
Tool uh
yeah
actually I'm curious what what do you
guys think is the better part of like do
you prefer the uh great Plateau or the
great Sky Island like which one of the
two do you think did a better job as a
tutorial
section great Plateau no contest Sky
Island
plau like obviously it's going to come
down to personal preference and whether
or not you
played uh both
games I do like the atmosphere of this
place a
lot it just doesn't feel as new oh wait
uh this
one
uh-oh uh-oh
nope do I still have weapons oh yeah we
do
plenty ow oh [__] I think I didn't take
any
damage I think I secretly have
invincibility on
which I always do when I capture footage
it's the last thing I want to do is
die and having to start my recording
over hi King
yo H I'll turn it off in a in the next
play
through because I'm basically just going
to be focusing on story stuff I want to
record all the stuff that raru has to
say here cuz he keeps giving you new
things as you progress through the the
the island he keeps popping up
everywhere I've been a Zelda fan for 25
years oh cool yeah think same no no not
not that long
right H pretty
close yeah I know how to roast stuff I'm
going to roast you
wait you're capturing footage without
the
prud yeah yeah without without the the
prad cuz I it's it's it's mostly going
to be dialogue and things like
that for the actual Ultra cam stuff
which is the free cam mod that I use for
my videos now uh that stuff it's is
better to just do that off
stream cuz it it's just boring it takes
a long time to set up the right shots
and all that
jazz today I'm making my first
anniversary about my Zelda tattoo oh
that's cool oh I wasn't paying
attention
ow what kind of tattoo do you
[Music]
have all right I'm just kiding
okay all that jazz yeah that's uh it's
kind of my
thing okay I think this is the part
where he shows up for the first time if
I'm I remember correctly so let me hit
record real
quick why aren't you taking damage I
still have my uh invincibility uh stuff
on
because when I capture footage I always
use Yuzu instead of my
switch it's easier that door will open
only to those with sufficient power
because I can just do everything from PC
I did not intend to startle
you it was I that spoke to you earlier
that arm originally belonged to me cuz
when I when I capture footage I normally
I have even more stuff turned on like
infinite arrows and in in
[Music]
stamina cuz you know when you're
capturing footage you you just want to
get it done you don't want to you want
don't want stuff to get in the way no I
cannot tell you how many times I've died
during recordings and it's just so
frustrating because you have to start
your recording all over again that arm
allow
open seems to have lost the power to do
so you might be able to restore it but
you would need to enter a place filled
with sacred
light the tattoo has the Twilight the
Triforce and zai sign and the shik eyes
well that sounds like a very complicated
tattoo did you record that fireworks
video with the ultra cam as well uh I
love it so
much oh thank you yeah yeah yeah that
was uh most of that was also used uh
like I also use the ultra cam for that
[Music]
one not all of it but a lot of shots I
took like two two shots of the same
event from different angles and Stitch
them
together that kind of sucks that I put
on the invincibility mod though but I'm
not going to turn it off right
now I don't even think you can you have
to just completely restart the whole
emulator it's kind of kind of
annoying uh okay that's it for the
recording yeah this is not a challenge
run or anything I'm just hanging out
recording footage talking about
things
are you using a mod manager no I don't
know anything about mods or how to set
them
up it's mostly just for convenience most
of the time at least it's uh for at
least when it comes to recording in
[Music]
footage but I don't I'm not going to
start a new playthrough on my switch my
actual switch because for some weird
reason Nintendo still does the same
thing they did with breath of the wild
where you cannot start start a second
playthrough on a like a different save
file unless it's massim mode in in the
case of bre wild
but you'll just over write your original
save and it's gone I like what what
happened to just having multiple save
files like in all the other games it's
it's such a weird
system I I just don't get
it and at least with uh Yuzu I can back
up my
saves put them in a like a backup folder
if I want to go back to a like an
earlier like I I have a 100% save file
at the ready for in case I need to
record footage of C
clothing
or oh wait I should record this
part oh thank you
byebye I forgot my
water yeah maybe it is better if they
focus on the new on a new Zelda game
instead of DLC I I I can see
that yeah always
hydrate that's why I have an alternate
profile on my switch oh yeah I guess
that works but it it it's kind of
ridiculous that we have to resort to
those kind like those kinds of
Tricks just have like three save file
slots like in the older games like how
hard can it
be don't you all think tears of the
kingdom was just break throughout 2.0
though uh I was expecting something a
bit different from the four Divine
beasts and
all yeah I guess in a way it is very
derivative a little bit more derivative
than I I personally hoped it would be
but like in in a world where breath wild
doesn't exist obviously TS tears
is like really really
good but because bre wild exists it's
kind of like yeah it's it's more of the
same that that that's for sure like if
you compare this to for example Majora's
Mask Aina of
time that that's
a that's such a like Major's mask felt
so different You know despite being in
the same engine having largely the same
Graphics you know that's also kind of
like just the nature of doing a direct
sequel like this in the same
world
but yeah I I personally would have
preferred if they went to a different
land
or a different
map I think that would have already
helped a
lot uh how should I tackle this one this
time I have a shield right
yeah can I climb this I forgot if I
can yeah I
can Tony
Hawk
oh
anticlimactic have you seen alien like
the movie
Alien yeah
I've seen all of them except
Resurrection I
think Tony Hawk falls
down I don't imagine myself playing
breath wild uh ever again after tears of
the Kingdom
uh kind of depends I don't think I'll
play either of these games a whole lot
after the next thing comes
around
I don't think these games have the same
replayability as some of the older games
which is not inherently a bad thing not
not everything has to be about
replayability but I think a lot of
breath of the wild and also this game is
kind of it's all about the mystery and
exploration like I don't particularly
enjoy collecting
trinkets like the cororo
stuff I it's just not for
me and they put even more of that in
this game so uh it's not really it's not
really my thing but because the the
older games were more more focused and
linear it's easier to go back to them
and just go through the whole Adventure
again whereas with this if you have to
100% this whole game again well not even
100% it but just go through the whole
thing again it's it's a bit more tedious
I guess
replay isn't very important in a game
exhibit outer Wilds yeah exactly it it
really just depends on the type of game
it it really does like uh for example uh
Resident Evil Village that one does have
good replayability but but it kind of
has to you know it's it's like a 10hour
main campaign like if if there if it
didn't have any
replayability that game would be
significantly worse
like I think I I I didn't even rush
through it and I managed to beat it in
like 12 hours but I I know people who've
done it in way way less like
nine like the the the idea that you have
to be able to keep playing a game and
playing it and playing it it it's just a
bit like it's a bit weird a bit of a
weird philosophy like movies don't go on
forever
either sometimes a thing has to come to
an end at some point you know I think
that in general as as people we I don't
know if that's always been the case but
especially lately I feel
like people are so obsessed with having
to get a sequel to everything if
something's good we need to get a sequel
to it and it almost always fails it's
almost always like it doesn't either
doesn't have the same impact or it ruins
some of the the lore like there are
examples obviously
but sometimes it's fine to have a oneof
you
know oh more stuff I can record hold
on like I'm right now I'm watching The
Outsider which is a series on HBO and it
only has one season because it's based
on a book by Stephen King and people
were like complaining saying like why
why did they cancel it the we should
have gotten a season 2 it was so good
it's like well it's the book ends at
some point and season 1 is just the
whole story of that book what would
season 2 even be about they would have
to invent new things like they did with
Game of Thrones in the last two seasons
and we we know that's not really going
to
work it's okay when when things not
every Everything has to have 10 seasons
even if it is really really good you
know I'm glad glad that they the last
season of stranger things is going to be
the last one cuz if we're going to have
the same situation as The Walking Dead
where it just refuses to end and it's
just getting
worse like then I I would rather see it
end gracefully than go out with a
whimper uh what do I do again oh
yeah I've got an
axe I should just use
this The Outsider is great both the book
and the series yeah it's surprisingly
well done it's I didn't read the book
personally I'm not a huge Stephen King
book guy but I have seen many of the
movies based on his Works uh I've
seen obviously I've seen
it I've seen 1408 which is one of my
favorite horror movies
ever which is also like that guy has
written so much stuff the his work eepic
say what you want about Stephen King but
his work ethic is
insane he has done so much
stuff the Mist was a really good movie
in my opinion although I did hate the
characters but that just the idea and
the ending was really
good one piece is still great though
well yeah some things are if you can
keep it going it's
fine but it's also fine if it just ends
you know not not everything has to go on
indefinitely like breaking bads stopped
at its height at at its peak and I think
that's for the
better
[Music]
uh actually I want to talk to Ru one one
last
time and then I will stop the
recording I'm troubled by the side of
the constructs we created they still
strive to fulfill their purpose even
when no one would benefit everyone who
would benefit is gone
I mean if it makes them
happy to see them toil away it Grieves
me so he really has no idea what's been
going on in the past like tens of
thousands of
years he doesn't even know that the sky
island like the the Temple of Time was
risen up into the sky which is kind of
weird because he does he's the one who
takes you here so unless he has like
some sort of spiritual connection to
these grounds or I think they could have
explained that part a little bit better
because he just pulls you up into the
sky and then the the the screen turns so
white they get a get a Fade to White and
then you're suddenly here and he's like
well I don't I don't know how we got
here or why this is all floating in the
sky now but you know qu armor yeah it
it's it's kind of like a final fantasy
type of thing like especially Final
Fantasy if I recall
10 like that one had a lot of stuff
where it just characters suddenly show
up in a completely new environment and
they don't explain how they got there
because they're they they themselves
probably had no idea how to explain
it I also wondered if how Ganondorf knew
of the ravaged hyro
Castle
uh I'm I'm not too sure I hated Final
Fantasy 10 yeah I also hated Final
Fantasy
13 actually 10 was okay to me I didn't
like the main character a whole
lot like I hate Titus I just hate him in
every way possible but I think 13 was
probably the worst of all of them like
the story in that game did not make any
sense
whatsoever uh how are you
sir oh yeah he's hunting let me stop the
recording how are there so many Final
Fantasy games well how are how are there
so many Zelda
games
did you play the avatar game no
no
no I like the Avatar movie the first one
I didn't like the second one very much
felt like a glorified Tech demo to
me but I hear it's pretty good and it
looks good
too uh I think wait where's the next
Shrine I think it's up there
somewhere
because Zelda is good well yeah fair
enough I mean Final Fantasy is good too
but there they've had a couple of oh got
to record this one what what does he
have to say I didn't even know he was
here I love the view of the Temple of
Time I always took a moment to
appreciate it whenever I passed by here
the garden of time was quiet the only
sound to be heard was the time bell
ringing in the the mornings and
evenings actually yeah where did all
this land mass come from because it sure
as heck did not come from the the great
Plateau like unless the Temple of Time
itself was the only thing lifted up into
the
sky but that's not what they're
implying like if you actually put them
side to side the two plateaus both in
the past and the present are almost
identical aside from a few trees and
things that are missing and you know the
the architecture like the Temple of Time
and the the zonai castle ru's castle I
guess hyu Castle in that
time I have not seen the boy and the
Heron yet but I will soon because I'm a
big jibbly
guy stop using reason monster yes go God
forbid we use reason to make sense of a
Story I mean obviously you don't have to
focus in on every little thing it is
still a fantasy
game uh
oh I'll just NAB this treasure treasure
real quick and then I'll be on my way oh
wait no you can't I
forgot
why does that screen turn black I don't
know why that keeps doing that I think
it's a setting
I accidentally turned off or turned on
actually you know what screw the screw
the
treasure we're not here to get
rich let me see how long do you think
the Zelda series is going to continue
before it gets old well kind of depends
on if it manages to reinvent itself
for the next decades or
so like I think there is a chance that
we might get a moment of
like where like maybe the series will go
on a small Hiatus for a
while but I don't see that happening
anytime
soon if the series can continue to
innovate which I'm sure they can because
it's Nintendo they're they're good at
that
stuff then I'm sure it's going to be
fine
like maybe the the open world formula
will get stale at some point and they're
going to go back to more linear stuff
just to spice it up
again
uh why do I hear battle music oh I see
you trying to sneak up on me
Pokemon keeps go doing the same thing
over and over again with no innovation
and it's still super popular despite
putting out mediocre games well that's
just the I guess the fan base they don't
want more which I you know to a certain
extent I can respect that where it's
like no just give us what we already
know uh and we'll be
happy
but you know
I'm not really going to be I'm not I'm
not going to be into that series at
all and you know I also think Pokemon is
kind of like because of its
demographic a lot of people will
eventually maybe kind of grow out of it
a little bit and then a whole new slew
of of of new fans will show up who
didn't play the previous
games I don't know I I cannot really
speak for the Pokemon fandom I think
they should demand better and it's kind
of annoying to see people defend lazy
decisions from a
company it's like do you want
to you know get mediocre stuff I mean if
you do then that's fine
but can you at least see why other
people feel different about
that I thought I grew out of Zelda after
Skyward Sword and before breath the W
yeah I I had the exact same experience
although in my case it wasn't not it
wasn't just growing out of it because I
I was
already like way into my 20s at that
point but yeah I just didn't like the
game and I thought that that it was just
the wrong direction for the series at
that
time but I also just wasn't in in a in a
very good mind space back
then like it wasn't just Zelda I didn't
like games in general
anymore it's just uh you know due to
personal stuff in
general which I'm not going to get into
too much right now but let's just say I
was not in a very good place during my
mid to late
20s which you know that that that isn't
to say that other people didn't like
Skyward Sword had a like similar
situation but that's how it was for
me Let Them
Fight I'm just going to take take this
stuff who do you think's going to win oh
okay well I think I think the construct
is going to win this
one
yep and then we collect The Spoils of
War I think Zelda make I don't think
Zelda maker is going to happen no
Nintendo already pretty much said
they're not doing it they don't see the
value in
it which I disagree with but who am I to
say what they should
do I just thought it was a good
idea I think it could have worked but
I am not the game design
[Music]
expert next Zelda should definitely be a
top- down traditional one well in
between the next 3D game I think they
should do 2D G uh like 2D zeldas again
for sure cuz that used to be the norm is
like you wait in between the bigger 3D
releases you get something to hold you
over man my graphics card is really
having a hard time right now I don't
know what's up I should probably send it
in to get it cleaned or
something I don't know in your country
but in Italy people are freezing because
it's zero degrees and there's me who's
in summer
clothes it is pretty cold here too yeah
we just had a few days of
frosts like it was like minus
5 I think it's
gone above zero again now cuz the ice is
melting Oh I thought it was
dead
dive there we
go
why didn't you do the shrine oh yeah
shoot you're completely right I'm so
used to just activating it so I have a
fast travel
point but I cannot fast travel yet I
guess now I just feel
stupid
luckily it's not that far
back in Brazil my region is on
fire
yeah no fast travel until you open the
door oh yeah that makes
sense should I get the long stick
uh
don't think raru hangs around these
parts jeez come
on I have a 3080 TI and it's still
having
trouble it is quite warm in here though
should turn down the hold on let me turn
off the uh heater heater for a
moment
so after we do all the shrines I'm going
to discuss a couple of story elements
with you guys and I'm I'm curious to
hear your opinions on
it uh let's see let's me let me check
out some
comments
what has been the most disappointing
aspect of Tears of the Kingdom for for
you uh the story for
sure like I have my grievances with the
game play the same way I did for breath
the
wild I don't think they fixed all of
breath to Wild's issues in fact that
they they didn't fix
most of breath aside from maybe the
weapon
durability but yeah the the the story
just doesn't make any sense to me I like
the that that's kind of also a thing
that I'm going to be addressing in my
video is like yeah you can you can enjoy
certain characters you can enjoy
certain story beats or set pieces
especially set pieces people kind of
confuse story with set pieces like you
can enjoy a certain part of it but that
doesn't make the story as a whole make
more sense or make the story as a whole
better you know that that that's kind of
my one of the points I'm trying to make
like you can you can appreciate the part
where you know link is unable to catch
Zelda in the beginning and then at the
end you you do that final Skydive after
the the the
fight and it makes sense you know it's
it's it's a great theme to put into the
game like he failed at catching her
first and then you get a get a do over
and this time he succeeds that's a
that's that's a good story arc or a good
a good set piece I should say you can
like you can like a lot of the thing I
like Sonia I like Sonia as a character
is
probably I would have love to see much
more of
her but that doesn't mean that the story
itself is
good
uh oh yeah it already selects it for
you and that's kind of been the thing
with the story of Tears of the Kingdom
for me personally is that the more I
think about it like good stories usually
get better the more you think about it
like the story of ocarine of time gets
better the more you understand about the
deeper meanings and the subtext and you
know there's there's it's it's
definitely not
perfect like I think they could have
done more with Ganondorf in that story
because he kind of just hangs out in his
castle for the the rest of like he won
after he after he wins he becomes just
lazy just plays the organ inside the
castle the whole day it's it's very
mustach twirling evil like typical
stereotypical evil guy but they did
improve on that in later Zelda games
though
so that there's
that
I don't know why this screen keeps
turning
black because it doesn't always do
that maybe it's because of ultra
cam I'll make sure to turn off the
invincibility and the ultra cam for the
next one cuz I'm not really going to use
it
anyway ref the wild story outshines
tears of the kingdoms uh in terms of
consistency yes for sure breath the wild
story at least made sense even though it
was very basic and you you basically get
the whole picture in the first two hours
of the game like there's really only two
big lore
expositions aside from the memories but
the memories are more or less things we
already know but you just get to see
it in more
detail you know you get some time with
the Champions and you get to see a
little bit more of their personality
which they should have done with the
sages in this game
too instead we get Demon King secret
Stone four times and that's
it well you know it's okay it's okay not
to like that part of the it's only one
part of of the game
oh
can I set him on
fire at least I didn't have infinite
stamina turned on that would have been
very
unfair uh
no I think I'm going to go for a
spear and a
spiky sword I
guess
oh I'll make some more weapons
later I'll be honest Zelda probably
should have just been the main
protagonist I feel like link was kind of
lost in the story when compared to the
rest of the characters well yeah the
most of the interesting stuff is
happening in the past and we don't see a
whole lot of
it like aside from the final
fight it's mostly just link dealing with
your typical oh this area has been been
plagued by this meanwhile Zelda is
actually living the ancient
past
but like I like I said a bit earlier I
think both sides in the whole is the
story good is it bad debate are
equally they're equally equally rightful
in their opinions because at the end of
the day it is just opinions but both
sides are also very obnoxious not all of
them of course in fact it's it's a small
minority like when it comes to the when
it comes to Camp I hate tears of the
Kingdom
story those people tend to pop up
everywhere to to to reiterate that they
don't like the story I'm like yeah okay
like I don't mind people doing that in
my actual like in the comments of my
videos because you know we're talking
about lore so you are more than in
within your right to voice your opinions
and your your love or hate for the story
uh in fact I encourage that and you it
doesn't matter if you don't like the
story if you do like it if I think
you're argument or your your post is
funny or or or valid or whatever you
will get a heart from
me uh but they will also pop up in areas
where it's like well we're not even
talking about story right now like I
I'll just be wishing people happy New
Year or making a joke on Twitter about
something completely unrelated and
someone just cannot help themselves
to squeeze themselves in between and be
like story this the story of T the
kingdom sucks and it's like yeah okay
there's a time and a place for
everything and we're we're not talking
about that kind of stuff right now you
know just save that stuff for videos
that talk actually talk about the lore
or go to go to Reddit to discuss it with
people and talk about how bad you think
the story is that's
fine but on the other uh like when it
comes to Camp I love the
story those people can also be very very
annoying at times like probably the most
annoying thing I keep seeing is people
telling you why you don't like it
because I I I've been pretty vocal about
it on at least on Twitter and in a few
podcasts that I'm not into the story of
this game at all like I in fact I think
I was the first of the bigger quote
unquote bigger Zelda creator to publicly
state that I didn't like the
story cuz that was I looked it up I
still have the the screenshot of the
tweet it was somewhere like in June like
the beginning of
June which was we were still smacked
like in the middle of the uh the the
honeymoon phase as they call it so it
was not a popular opinion at
all but you know since then other
creators have come forth about it
too and it's just very annoying when
someone else is going to tell you why
you don't like it it's like well how how
do you know why I don't like it like why
are you trying to project your
expectation upon me like I've had people
tell me that I don't like the story
because I did not predict it like my
theory some of my it invalidated some of
my theories and I'm like do you even
know how the Zelda Comm the Zelda lore
Community Works we're used to getting
things wrong we get wrong stuff wrong
all the time plus do you do you really
think I want to predict the entire story
of of Tears of the Kingdom beforehand
and have no surprises no of course not
I'm just coming up with theories just
coming up with ideas and observations
and I realize all too well that most of
them are probably going to be
wrong and the stuff that does end up
being right well I mean power to you if
if you did predict something right
that's also really cool
but like why do you why do you insinuate
that like you you don't like it because
of a b c
whatever it's like you don't know me I
haven't even like in my original tweet I
only said I didn't like the story I I
purposely held off from telling people
why I didn't like the story I think the
only thing I said was just as a
clarification like no it's not because
of the timeline stuff it's not because
it doesn't fit into the timeline because
I knew people were going to make that
assumption as well you're like oh you
just don't like it because it doesn't
fit into your little timeline thing it's
like no if if if it was a self-standing
story I wouldn't have liked it either
way even if it did tie into the the rest
of the timeline like would it have
helped if they did at least acknowledge
it yeah I think it would
have the same way it did for the Wind
Waker but to say that the story I don't
like the story because it doesn't fit
into the timeline no no I I really could
not care less if it fits into the into
the timeline at least not not in terms
of my grievances let's just put it that
way so yeah like I said both sides can
be equally annoying to deal with
it doesn't matter which Camp you are in
people will tell you why you are wrong
even though it's an
opinion oh that's
not come
on there we
go so if you don't like the story all
the power to you if you do like the
story same goes for
you
like probably the worst argument I've I
keep hearing is people just love to hate
this game it's like no that's not that's
not how it
works especially in the case of Zelda
crate I've seen
people uh
like blame people like
zeltic for that exact reason like zeltic
stands to gain nothing from not liking
the story in fact he his it's too
Channel's best benefit that tears of the
kingdom does have a great story and tons
and tons of interesting lore to draw
inspiration and ideas from like why why
would he want to hate on Zelda just for
the for the sake of it that that that
doesn't make any
sense I am the last person like me
people like me people like zeltic we are
the the the last people who benefit from
tears the kingdom not having a great
great
story in fact my NE my next video is
probably going to going to be self-
sabotage at least a little bit I hope
people will still continue to to to
watch my
channel and understand that it's just
opinions at the end of the day but you
know I do have to stay true to myself I
cannot change the way I feel about
it but I I will substantiate my claims
about this story as best as I can I'm
not just going to be shouting at the
screen
I did actually give it a lot of thought
as to why I feel that way
and I have everything written down when
it comes to the plot points that I don't
like
or which I do I I don't think make any
sense yeah disappointed and hate are
very very different things for sure
absolutely people often confuse the too
like you're just a hater like what does
that even
mean like sure haters exist but they're
usually not the people who love
something unless it's Star Wars Maybe
Star Wars fans are the
worst even the biggest Zelda or the
biggest Star Wars channels
who really like I just don't get the
feeling that they actually love their
own fandom or their own franchise
like everything just sucks everything is
bad even when there there's
nothing then when there's no information
about it yet they're already talking
about oh this is going to fail it's like
you just want you just want the
franchise to fail cuz that doesn't
really sound like being a fan of
something you
know but but in my case it's no no you
don't have to feel attack it's a very
small minority of the like in the
grander scheme of things most people go
and see Star Wars
movies that they're not really bothered
by any of
that but I do sometimes feel like Star
Wars fans hate their own franchise a
lot and it's not just because of Disney
although I do not think Disney does a
very good job with the franchise
at all but it was already kind of bad
before Disney like the prequels aside
from Revenge of the S were not that
great and I have Nostalgia for those
movies all of them in fact The Phantom
Menace was one of the first movies I
ever saw in
theater aside from maybe Lion King or
something same with Halo fans I cannot
speak to speak about by that I I don't
know anything about Halo or it's
fandom I just know the series was
apparently very very
bad yeah I just uh mentioned that before
I don't know why it does that I think
it's like an emulator
problem I think it's because the I have
Ultra cam
on which I'm not using right now but it
does affect some of the graphical
settings
so I think that's why I don't know I
have no idea but I'm too lazy to fix it
now because then I have to exit the game
and reboot it and H that takes
time also High
Shin Ultra cam yeah that's uh that's the
free cam mod that I used for my last
video
I actually don't know if I can activate
it right
now or if that would mess up mess up oh
here we
go so this is how you capture footage
you just hit U on the keyboard and then
you have free control over the camera
and then you can set like a key frame
for example here you can press seven and
then go over here
press seven
again and then just let it play
out so there you go and then you can
just turn it off
again I've only had this mod for since
the last video I done like not the
fireworks one with the the one before
that before before that one I was using
a first person mod mod which is way more
limited which is also what I use for
life as Ain by the way the first person
mod yeah it's like a replay mod or like
camera mode I guess although it doesn't
freeze everything in the
game if
you're like I I I did put a link to it
because it's obviously it's not the
fruit of my labors I just it's just a
tool that I use to make my videos more
cinematic I don't care if Nintendo
approves yes or no
I I don't have a relationship with them
it's my own I dumped my own game to PC I
can do whatever I want with
it as long as I don't distribute
anything or make money of selling
mods I should be
good I'm not here to please a big
multi-billion dollar company
so yeah I okay here it does make sense
that the screen is black because oh you
can see the stamina meter in the
background
so uh let's
see let's hope you're good
yeah well I I'm not actively promoting
stuff you know the I know people have
gotten into trouble like uh
uh what's his name
again the the the the famous streamer
guy who got into trouble with the tears
of the Kingdom oh not not tears of the
Kingdom bre the Wilds mod yeah Point
Crow yeah yeah
yeah but he was like overly active with
it and making videos specifically about
modding which I personally I I have no
trouble with that cu I think once a game
is out there and you paid for it and you
as long as you dump the ROM to your own
computer and you first support the game
after that I think it's free
game I think we should be able to do
whatever as long as there's not like big
money involved I think we should be able
to do things as we please as a
community it's the same way valve
approaches
things
like obviously you cannot create a mod
of a game and then sell it to other
people like actually sell it like
physically and being like you know
because then you're just boot lagging
stuff at that
point but extending like imagine if we
didn't have the
randomizers how awesome are the
randomizers and how much have they
extended the lifespan of games like
arine of
time I have not given you permission to
use
those yeah Point Crow did offer money I
think that's where he went wrong I think
he should have just you know because
nobody really like I I'm okay with
people
supporting modders like on patreon
because that's donations right that's
not really like a salary or you're not
physically making money off of a product
you're just asking for support for the
stuff that you do you can do anything
and get sponsored you can do nothing and
get sponsored for it or get do like get
donations some people use patreon
and uh what's the other one there's
another one
like if they get sued or something they
will be like hey can you guys help me
pay for a
lawyer but that's like you you can
either support people or you
don't but actually putting a bounty on
something people would do for free
anyway like nobody as far as I know
nobody ever paid for the
randomizers it was just a passion
project people wanted to do
yeah coffee and of course you have stuff
like Kickstarter
and uh what are your thoughts on say on
Bandit saying tears of the kingdom was
just glorified DLC is that what Bandit
said I I haven't seen every single video
of him about it oh it's raru let me
record his conversation real
quick what does he have to
say the time Bell that sounds from the
Temple of Time rings at a set time each
morning in evening along with the
constructs we woke to the sound of the
Bell when we heard it in the evening we
knew it was time to
rest wow what an Innovative
system
it also played a part in our traditional
ceremonies in a way it was like this
place is beating
heart the sight of the temple and the
sounds of its Bells stir fond memories
in
me that's
nice by
hi he had such an early bedtime yeah
he's a responsible
guy I I've been sleeping much better
lately as well well cuz I really screwed
up my uh sleeping schedule after the
game
awards like the game awards broke my
sleeping schedule and it took me weeks
and weeks and then at that point it was
almost time for New Year's anyway so I
was like I might as well just stay up
late or else I'm going to fall asleep at
10: before the turn of the
hour uh let me see let
me trade in some uh
jet lag can feel like a disease oh yeah
for
sure but I've been going to bed at
normal times now for at least about a
week now and it's already it it makes
such a big difference in how you feel
across the whole
day like I don't want to take naps I
don't want to I I have much more energy
energy to do what I
want that was a little bit of Dutch
slipping in there
energy
energy I work third shift so sleep is
fun yeah I can
imagine uh let me see let me see let me
see I don't normally do that but
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'll I'll do it this one
time after that you guys are on your
own I'm gonna ma Mad Max this
guy if anyone has seen that
movie
how about I just hit
him uhoh uhoh no don't go
back there we
go what a lovely
day
I need to fix my sleeping schedule but
school work and 3D modeling work doesn't
really help yeah I can I can I can see
that that's why I stop working after
like
7 except for today because I'm streaming
I don't really see this as work
necessarily oh I don't have any cold
protection but I do have my
invincibility on so it doesn't really
matter uh I actually forgot how you get
across this
one I honestly I don't even think I did
it the intended way I think I climbed up
that part right there
oh yeah I I like climbed up through here
which maybe I should just do
that use a hook and a mine
card
oh I guess so I'm just going to do it
the stuff stupid
way besides I want to check out there
maybe Ru is going to be there
anyway there's more than one way to get
get to get two places in this game
that's one thing I do like about
it about the exploration part I
mean Peak fan placement yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah I know I
know
I'm not an engineer
man I don't really need to beat the con
construct I'm mostly just rushing
through just to get to the story
elements
uh I should have probably done
that uh uh uh do I have a torch actually
I don't think so
but just do it this
way
they should teach tears of the Kingdom
in engineering schools I'm sure they
will to some degree oh there's raru
again oh but if I talk to him my my
torch is going to go out isn't
it
uh let me
see yep of course he puts out his torch
cuz you cannot speak to people with with
a torchure in your hand in case you ever
tried that in real life it's
impossible yeah the physics they really
put a lot of effort into that for
sure uh drag draconic Crescent
says I hope in the next game they will
have proper Dungeons and mini
dungeons I would remove spelunking to
have mini dungeons that give heart
containers or heart pieces I don't
really care what the reward is I I think
it's all a means to the same
goal but I do yeah I I do agree at least
in terms of the whole main dungeons for
sure I don't think the ones in this game
were they were not a good replacement at
least not for me not not everyone is g
to agree with that one for
sure some people like it
some people like that you don't have to
invest hours into one dungeon I I do I
think as long as you have save points or
something that that would be one way to
solve it I guess just have checkpoints a
bit like the souls
games instead of always having to start
all the way from from the beginning
again or start at the entrance I should
say oh I think here you don't get cold
because it's inside of a
cave well I I do think the shrine
concept is it's played it's overstate
it's welcome at this
point even though the the ones in this
game are more
fun I think
but it is time for something new after
this just to be like again like do the
exact same thing again like go to all
the shrines yeah that's not going to
work they're they're going to have to
come up
with with something
new which I'm sure they
will
uh oh that's
that's a waste of that
one uh which weapon am I holding
actually
oh it's not the best weapon to use in
this
situation
hello
there we
go the tears of the Kingdom once felt
more like pretend old dungeons whereas
the beasts were unique I think
they the the the variety of the dungeons
in in this games is is
better but the beasts were indeed more
unique it's just a shame that they copy
pasted it four times I think maybe they
could have done something with that to
make it stand out a bit
more but they weren't very long so most
people don't even really consider them
dungeons in
general it's more like just a bigger
bigger
Shrine give me all the
stuff the fire temple was just okay yeah
I did like the music in that one but it
wasn't the
you can cheese it pretty
easily I think the fact that you can use
Zone ey devices inside the dungeons kind
of hurt that
one which you are not if I remember
correctly you're not able to do that in
the shrines so it's it's a bit weird
it's a weird weird
decision uh oh I remember
this I was stuck here for a little while
during my first playthrough
because you have to make it all the way
up to that
[Music]
thing uh wait let me
just there should be spicy pepper
somewhere along the way
though uh
yeah
if I remember correctly there there are
peppers here
somewhere you can climb up the route
yeah but
I oh wait I have in invincibility on it
doesn't even matter I can just run
through this whole area if I really
wanted
to but I'm just going to pretend like I
am vulnerable
oh there we
go do I have a zai cooking thing oh yeah
I
do so I can just make
things I miss na'vi shrieking at me
every five minutes
yeah that was Peak Zelda for
sure you know what I'm just going to
throw some spicy peppers in
there just just so he stops shivering
you
know problem is that most of what people
say they want ends up being
somewhat
gting I don't know what that means like
I hear a lot of souls like comparisons
but that cuts out the part of the fan
base that just are just
casuals well I don't necessarily think
that having more challenging dungeons is
like cutting off a part of the fan base
though cuz Zelda dungeons have never
really been that hard like maybe the the
water yeah you can say like oh what
about the water temple that that was one
time and even that one was it wasn't
even that difficult if you really knew
what to do like if I could figure it out
at 12 then anyone
can I don't I don't have to be
here but you know just have something
like I I would definitely not want to go
back back to the NES difficulty you know
but for sure that was too
much like Zelda 1 and Zelda 2
are excuse my French just
[__] they really
are at least when it comes to difficulty
I love I love replaying them now
because I know how the games work but by
God was that game
hard and I agree if you really want to
play a hard game then you can just pick
up a Souls
light I don't necessarily think Zelda
has to be for
everyone but it should at least try to
widen uh a little bit when it comes to
oh
wait uh oh yeah I can just skim me along
this Edge shimmy along
this there we
go yeah I can make
that yeah no game is for everyone it's
it's impossible trying to please
everyone
is it's almost always going to lead to
your
downfall and what the heck the the fact
that people even think that's a
something that should happen to any game
it's kind of weird I I remember hearing
people complain that Resident Evil was
too scary so they kind of tone down
Resident Evil 8 I'm like who are these
people who pick up a horror game and
then complain that it's too
scary you're playing a horror game what
what did you
expect well in the case of Tears of the
Kingdom I think it's just they focused
so much on the gameplay aspects
especially the physics that they kind of
cheaped out on on other levels because
it just wasn't enough
time
wow okay never never mind uh but yeah
the like the story some people will say
or or or will make the argument that you
know Zelda has never been about story
stories they Nintendo even admits that
Stories the stories in Zelda games are
an
afterthought and you know that's true
the the story is an afterthought that's
they literally say that in hyu Storia
they say like you could consider
stories in Zelda games like as something
we come up with at the end or kind of
just we retrofitted into the the the
gameplay area but just because something
is done done or isn't the main focus or
it's done afterwards doesn't mean it has
to be bad or that it doesn't matter
because that's just you know you can
write stories or design games in any way
you
want like Jr or talken started writing
his stories by drawing maps not every
writer is going to do it that
way
I think in this case they just H had
someone on the writing team who just
didn't understand how to write a like a
good story and I'm not talking about
like oh they have to know everything
about Zelda lore and they have to
because you know some I do agree some
people take that stuff too far some
people just go way out of like they're
just expecting people to remember things
from game games like from from the from
the 80s and 90s where I'm like
well I mean that's not
necessary you don't have to remember
every little detail about about the lore
to write a decent story for this game
it's more like the biggest problems I
have with this story is just the
character motivations they don't not
they do not make any sense at all if you
really sit down and think about
it everything these character do feels
like they don't want to win this battle
against the demon king at all like
they're they're purposely withholding
information from each other they're not
making any sense they don't explain
themselves they are purposely dumb about
a lot of
things which I you know I can give tons
and tons of examples but I think it's
best if you just watch the video about
that at some point I will dive into a
few of them in a moment
here like breath wild had a very simple
story but I cannot really point to
anything in that story that made me
angry in that same
way at least most of what happened made
made sense you know what I
mean it wasn't like why why is that
character not doing this or why aren't
they aren't they telling each other
about that or because it it already
happened that that was kind of like both
the strength and weakness of breath to
Wild storytelling is that most of the
things you learn in that game are things
that have already happened and you have
no control over it like you cannot
change the outcome in this all you can
do is defeat Calamity
genon and make sure
you you know save the world from
anything like that happening
again but you cannot change the death of
the Champions you cannot change anything
the death of the
king it's all been done it's already
it's already
happened oh wait I can just use a send
of course keep forgetting about this
ability such a great tool
oh yeah aine of time did have flaws but
I cannot think of a single Z game a
Zelda story at
least that annoyed me in the same way as
this game did at least in terms of story
I'm purely talking about story I'm not
talking about gameplay I'm not talking
about game design of course that that's
all different like every game has story
flaws I fully acknowledge that uh
Twilight Princess it didn't make any
sense that Zelda just shows up at the
end and she's just fine even though we
saw her sacrificing him herself to save
midna like it's fine that she it's not
the problem is not that she's she comes
back because she's Zelda obviously she's
not going to be dead forever because
Nintendo doesn't take risks like that
but they don't even explain how she is
suddenly there and that that kind of
stuff you just you have to explain that
kind of stuff before you people are not
just going to accept that you at least
have
to well you know I'm repeating myself
but same goes for like the the like
Ganondorf in ocy of time he doesn't
after the the Midway point he doesn't
really do anything he just sits in his
castle playing the organ it's like H
they could have done
more but like I said they did improve
upon that in the Wind Waker for example
where he does show up now and again and
his motivations are more clear he his
he's actually surprisingly
sympathetic they gave him a lot more
personality so they they definitely
improved on that
but with this story I just it's just one
thing after another where I'm just like
why
how why did they go for
this
oh wait the the the the the clothing
there's a
chest uh right
yeah and a free zone I
charge tears Ganondorf is evil for the
sake of evil and it's it's also and it's
so
disappointing uh yeah I agree I
agree
like if you compare to previous villains
and Dynamics between the villains like
Twilight Princess for example the way
Zant was portrayed how he's he starts
off as this this really evil badass guy
and it turns out he's actually very
pathetic like that's character
development and you actually kind of see
where he's coming from he was
manipulated by Ganondorf and Ganondorf
himself was kind of like an after
thought like he was just secretly the
puppet master in the background even
though they kind of do hint at the his
presence during the arbitus grounds
but I can always appreciate if they do
something more with a villain besides
just hahaa I'm going to take over the
world cuz I'm evil you
see
that's why most people still agree like
Wind Waker Ganondorf was Peak Ganondorf
CU he actually got some character
development
finally like him and the King were just
holding on to the the past and they
didn't want to let go of the kingdom of
Hyrule and all the pain and suffering
that it has caused over the centuries
since its existence and at the very end
the kind of acknowledges it it's like
yeah you you and me like me and
Ganondorf we just we're relics of the
past it's time to give the the future
back to the younger
generation
like I have my problems with the Wind
Waker especially in terms of like I
thought the dungeons were too easy in
that game I think only having five
dungeons was a little bit disappointing
for a Mainline 3D Zelda game like I know
maor's mask had only four but that was
like developed in a
year but again they rectified that with
Twilight Princess luckily Twilight
Princess has an insane amount of
dungeons like they had to cut Corners
With the Wind Waker I'm pretty sure they
wanted to include more dungeons but just
to just to do those three opening
Dungeons and then be like oh there's
only two more wow that's well if you
don't count ganon's Tower of
course but yeah
like like only two more dungeons
what I remember being kind of
disappointed by
that but the story made up for it same
with Skyward Sword the game play
suffered a little bit because of its
need to tell a big linear
story but what is there is very very
good but also has flaws again it's time
travel stuff they never seem to get that
stuff right in
Zelda or in media as as a whole I think
there's literally only one series that
did time travel good and that's dark
dark is the only series I know that
absolutely nailed the time travel part
of
it every other movie that's ever been
made that has time travel if you really
really think about the implications and
how it works you're
like you will find things that doesn't
make any sense because time travel is
difficult it's such an intangible
concept to our human brain we live in a
linear time so just wrapping our head
around how time travel would even work
would it exist in the in the in the real
world it's just it's just very difficult
so I'm not going to blame I'm not even
going to really blame tears of the
Kingdom for that fact because tears of
the Kingdom's time travel does not make
any sense sense
whatsoever like the mural is already
there like they kind of imply that it's
a time like a closed time Loop but also
there's stuff that completely
contradicts that including raru himself
he's like
yeah I know you like the stuff you saw
with Ganondorf is really terrible but
that that was a future that that all
happened because you weren't here it's
like yeah yes she was if it's a close
time Loop it would always play out the
same
way and if it's not a like a closed time
Loop how does Ganondorf recognize Link
and Zelda at the beginning why is the
mural there like it's it is it's a close
time Loop that's the only
option so either raru is just
wrong or the the writers didn't really
think it through very well I don't know
cuz if you really think about it I think
they imply that the moment Zelda travels
into the past that's at that very moment
that's when the light dragon and some of
the other stuff kind of just pops into
existence but realistically speaking if
it's
a quote unquote time Loop where whatever
happened in the past will always happen
the way it because it's not like Zelda
changes anything about the the
past like realistically speaking there
should always be a light dragon cuz it
it already happened
before but you know it's the same
problem with Skyward Sword like how can
link defeat the m in the past but then
also they still had to kill him with the
Triforce in the future he should not
exist because it's always bound to
happen that
way it's
a it's the the the the what's it called
s of storms Paradox but on a much bigger
level some things just don't make sense
raru knows nothing about time travel
yeah
exactly that's why I said dark that the
series is dark if you haven't seen that
series you should absolutely watch it if
you like time travel
stuff you will be blown away by that
series
because they did it so perfectly
everything at in the end everything made
sense there isn't the single moment in
that Series where you're
like where it doesn't make
sense they really thought that went
through very very
well every other movie I've ever seen
that features time travel there's stuff
you can complain about where it's like
no that that wouldn't work
that that doesn't make
sense no he's just
dumb oh thank you Joe Kelly
uh let me see selling my PS5 because I
want to get rid of some creative
blocks that's I mean that's that's
respectable we'll always keep my switch
especially for Zelda your fireworks
video needs to go viral by the way oh
thank you yeah I gotta be honest man the
views in general
for like Zelda videos have not been
great not just for me like for all the
Zelda
creators that's why I said uh before
is let's not pretend like there's
nothing going on with the lore in this
game because clearly something is going
on the the interest in in the lore at
least in the lore I I cannot speak for
the gameplay I don't know how speedr
Runners are doing in terms of views and
all that kind of stuff but at least when
it comes
to lore
videos I mean I
I it's not going well man it's not going
well at
all the fact that zeltic last tear of
the Kingdom
videos still has not broken 100K views
after about a week that that means that
something is definitely
up cuz pretty much every video he does
gets at least 100K
views yeah I'm playing I'm playing on
Yuzu because I'm I'm just capturing
footage mostly I'm not playing for the
for the game play no
no uh no Elite gamer moments
here let's not just that the game's lore
is disappointing there's just not a
whole lot of it there's not enough
lore because it's the same map and they
didn't really add much in terms of like
with breath weld you had so much new
stuff because the whole map was new you
know you had all these buildings and all
these new places and you you could and
and then of course we also got creating
a champion after that which meant you
could even uh you get you can draw even
more ideas from it I don't think we're
going to get a creating a champion
equivalent for this one I think the art
book is the only thing we're going to
get I think they're just going to move
on to the next
one but like for example The Sky Islands
there there's just not a whole lot to it
there's not a whole lot you can
find and I've trust me I have tried and
many other creators are trying their
absolute
best
it's not like we don't want to make
videos about this game when it comes to
lore it's just so difficult to find
things that are not only interesting but
that are you can actually put some proof
behind and do something cool with you
know yeah I'm sure it's possible but you
really really have to struggle and you
really have to try to get it
done uh like you almost have to have to
force yourself whereas before it was
almost effort uh at least for me it was
almost
effortless so when when people say like
you guys haven't been creating a lot of
videos yeah well that's why it's mostly
because it's just very difficult to come
up with ideas for this
one and that's just that's just how it
is I wish that wasn't the case but
you know I'm I'm currently thinking
about at least like I don't want to
sound too depressing because obviously
it's just a video game at the end of the
day and I'm sure in the future with new
Zelda games it's going to be fine
again
but currently I would have to make at
least a video per week if I want to earn
the same amount of money from it that I
did before when I was only doing one or
two videos per month with a lot of
production
value because yeah you can make VI four
videos that get like 20K views or you
can make one that gets
100K it's uh whatever you want but I'm
not really a mass producer of content
that's not never been my
style oh hey Clifford yeah I am I am
noticing
you
sorry I I was watching my own
gamepl oh yeah for sure it is it is my
own uh job but I made a my own conscious
choice
to focus more on on production quality
than just hammering out videos like
grinding out videos like
crazy
what are you working on right now uh I'm
working on my critique of the
story and it's going to be a long one
it's probably going to be my longest
video I've ever made I'm expecting it to
be at least an hour maybe hour and a
half like I said I'm not just gonna like
uh complain about a story
I actually want to give you reasons
valid reasons why not because I want to
convince people but I I at least want
people to take the criticisms that some
of us do have seriously you know if
you're just screaming into the void like
I don't like the story of Tears of the
Kingdom you're not really going
to gain any notoriety or respect from
other people you're not going to
convince anyone you're not you like I
said you don't have to convince uh
people necessarily but you can at at
least let them know where you're coming
from and they might even get a better
understanding of why you think that
way so I I've been wanting to do this
video for a while now but I I wanted to
make
sure that I word it
correctly will you be giving any ways to
improve the story in the video uh yeah I
might
I mean there's a lot to it it's not just
the main narrative it's also the lack of
environmental storytelling it's the uh
the side content the the Side Story so
so to
speak uh no that's not how it
goes
yeah when when the two
meet there we
go
so it's going to be first I thought
maybe I should split it up into multiple
Parts like one part specifically talking
about the main narrative and then one
part about the environmental
storytelling and the side side lore
because for example I'm not when I'm
talking about the main narrative I'm not
really going to going to get
into like what happened to the shika
technology cuz that's not really
relevant to the main
story you know if we we View this as it
as its own entity pretend like bre wild
doesn't exist just purely look at this
story as its own
thing
then you know those complaints are not
going to be completely different than
the side content and the fact that it
doesn't
really elaborate on some things that
shouldn't that that the game should like
the fact that they have to come out
afterwards in interviews and explain
things that they could have easily
explained with a few
sentences in the game itself that kind
of speaks volumes that they didn't
really think that part through very
well yeah tears of the kingdom is a
great is a really good game uh gameplay
wise for
sure and even storywise it does have
things that I really like and I hope
they will do again in in the future I
think voice acting is definitely
something that should stay
oh wait I don't have enough Zone I for
that like I the some of the characters
were very very well
done some of the themes are very
effective like it's not all bad it's not
all
Grim in fact I think this video is going
to be fun for people because it's going
to have uh
it's also going to have quite a bit of
humor in it
too because some things in this story
are just really really funny when you
really think about
it like for example the way uh Ganondorf
kills
Sonia like if you really sit down and
think about it like what was his plan
actually in that situation because he
disguises himself as
Zelda and then he tries to throw a knife
at her and that doesn't work and then he
just suddenly he comes up behind her and
punches her so hard in the back that she
dies and it's like what exactly like did
he plan that like did he actually think
to himself like all right I'm going to
pretend to be Zelda I'm going to make a
fake Zelda and I'm going to just lure
her out and then in case it doesn't work
I'm going to be what like sitting in the
bushes behind her somewhere and I'm just
going to walk up and punch her punch her
to
death like I just imagine in my head
seeing him plan that thing out and then
he still pretends like ha it's all going
according to plan I don't know there's
just something very funny about that
whole situation it doesn't make any
sense especially the fact that Zelda is
almost smug about it like did you really
think we hadn't seen through your facade
or do do you really think we didn't
notice your deceit or whatever like
they're so confident they got Ganondorf
by the balls at that point and then he
just suddenly shows up plan b or plan Z
like Jake says and just you
know wops
her
oh so it's it's it's also going to be a
funny video cuz I I do think there's
humor to criti ISM as
well there there should be at
least if you're just going to be
complaining uh and pretend like it's the
worst thing you've ever experienced or
whatever
then you're not just doing yourself a
this service because you're going to
be stressing yourself out but it's also
going to be jarring for your audience
because at some point you do have to
kind of Step step back and realize it's
just a it's just a [__] video game at
the end of the day you know you we're
not talking about politics here or
complex social issues it's it's a video
game it's so trivial it it should not be
something that occupies your mind for
most of the
day and like I said it's just one game
out of 20 something like that now 20
games one game not resonating with you
is not the end of the world not when you
have 20 games to choose from and many
more to come for
sure uh don what are your thoughts on
the ending of the game I thought the
ending was one of the best endings in
any Zelda game so far probably it's a
very climactic ending
and it was more of a satisfying ending
than breath the wild was because in
breath the wild it was almost on the
same level as you did it congratulations
hero and then just roll credits at least
here they kind of gave it a little bit
of closure and everybody comes together
in the end see you have managed to open
the door you haven't fully recovered yet
but that is to be
expected Don in your newest video you
will talk about what happens I
visiting that link just defeat Calamity
gon and then years
later Lincoln zelden notice people are
getting sick because of the Gloom coming
out the castle coming out of the
castle I am so happy that
uh yeah well I think didn't Nintendo
black crisis already do a good video
about the whole Gloom
stuff how it was making people sick
and your winner yeah
exactly exactly now is up to you it's on
that
level but I I I feel like that was kind
of the point because they were trying to
emulate the first Zelda with breath the
wild so they they didn't really put a
lot of but of course that's not a valid
excuse because dark Beast Ganon was one
of the worst boss fights ever in any
Zelda
game Calamity Ganon itself was
okay it was actually kind of souls likee
almost in terms of difficulty unless
you're a speedrunner of course but
that's beside the
point but yeah this uh the the the final
fight in this game is way way way way
better so good that I would definitely
put it up there with some of the best
endings Al also thematically I think it
worked very
well like the the whole two
dragons the fact that link catches Zelda
after
skydiving oh you're talking about the
dragon problem how they resolve that
yeah okay that that a that's kind of a
different story I I get why they did
it cuz Nintendo just doesn't take risks
like that where they're like yeah
Zelda's dead now for or Zelda's a dragon
now
forever it's just how it is Nintendo
doesn't do that kind of stuff they're
not going to hit you with a surprise
twist or like a big
risk but it it is very like plot Wise
It's very very convenient cuz they do
set it up like once you become a dragon
it's irreversible it's you will lose
yourself it's there there's no going
back after
that and then suddenly it is it is a bit
like
uh like I think it would have been
better if she just stayed a dragon at
the
end as sad as that is it it would be
Bittersweet I guess as an
ending
so I guess not everything about the
ending is perfect
but again I I understand why they did
it does Zelda keeper Stone after being
UND dragoned I I don't know actually I
don't think so but that that would also
mean that the secret Stones they can be
destroyed by swallowing them
I'm not sure actually
that's I mean for sure Ganondorf stone
is gone oh there she is speaking of the
devil I hate that my pre-release
assumption about zonai was right for the
most part the zonai once existed buildt
some stuff then disappeared the end oh
the end zelatin will not elaborate more
on this yeah we for a game about all
about the zonai we know surprisingly
little about the
zonai link it's not my biggest gripe
with the story but it is something I
would have you must find me I would have
preferred it if they fleshed it out a
little bit
more but that's the that's kind of the
the core the core issue the core problem
with this game in general is that you're
you're stuck with this uh with the
memory format again and there's only so
many memories you can include in the
game so you're automatically going to be
limited in terms of what you can tell
well like the the amount of story you
can tell about the past whereas if link
actually travel to the Past himself or
you play a Zelda in the past or
something like that then you have much
more time that that's why it's such a
shame too because I really like Sonia as
a character I want to learn more about
that time period and about her and her
reign as Queen and uh you know the
people that lived around that time but
you don't really get any of that it's
just really short cutcenes and they're
just popping up in all kinds of places
you don't know why they went there or
how they got there like we don't even
know why they went to that underground
chamber to face Ganondorf like did they
challenge him to a to to a fight there
deep deep underground or why why would
they do do
that why would Ganondorf uh even
entertain them to to face them in in
battle in that room because the room
seems like it was set up for some sort
of ritual so I always assumed like oh
they're going to seal Ganondorf and then
take his body to this underground
chamber to keep it hidden but no they
actually duke it out in that same room
why why are they there and what is that
place yeah exactly what what what even
is that place if it wasn't like was it
some sort of battle arena
or it it really they really didn't think
that part through very
well like the the room itself is cool
and I I loved uh exploring it or seeing
it the first time I I thought it was it
was intim oh my God it's a tree but yeah
I I love being there and and I like the
atmosphere of
it but it would have made much more
sense if they faced him here for example
right in front of where the castle would
one day we be built or on the sacred
grounds or you know something along
those lines that just outside somewhere
they faced his army
or like neither of these two parties has
any benefit of locking themselves in a
small room on the ground
somewhere Don so can people see the sky
islands once the upheaval happens uh and
the cloud barrier is destroyed I think
so yeah cuz there are people who
reference the islands in fact uh you
you'll see that in a in a minute uh Pura
actually points to the great sky island
and she said like uh she will say
something like uh you came from all the
way up
there so I think once the the cloud
barrier dissipates or whatever it is
that prevented people from seeing the
islands that's
when people start seeing them like even
this this guy was looking
up
oh the stone tablets were nice but sort
of minor yeah they don't really reveal
much that we didn't already know I think
I would have to reread
them like I was expecting those tablets
to maybe explain something about raru
and Sonia having a kid for
example like maybe she was the nurse
made like she may have been a previous
incarnation of impa or something who
took care of their child and but
no they still do not explain how someone
can be related by blood when both
characters
die oh man the performance is really
bad yeah a lot of well that's one thing
that I feel like some people take it a
little bit too far is like when they're
complaining that certain characters
don't recognize you it's like well I
mean does it does that part really
really matter all that much like the
fact that one guy who I spent like five
minutes with in the previous game to
solve a shrine puzzle doesn't know who I
am anymore it's been like isn't this
game supposed to take place like four or
five years ago like I've I've talked to
people for longer than that and I
wouldn't recognize them today probably
also because I'm bad with fa with faces
but you
know
yeah it's running like Pokemon Scarlet
right now but that that's just a problem
with my I've been having some problems
with my video card I think it needs a
good cleaning or
something I've been really having some
issues with
it I think it was implied that he
stabbed there uh I'm not sure if you
look at the frame he's he still has the
sword on his hip I I think he just
punches her to death now where have you
been linky you're not a ghost are
you it's Pur yeah one punch
interesting oh thanks uh
adenor one step at a time it was really
fun to work work on that one because I
didn't have to do a voice over for a
change
you can even hear the spine cracking oh
my God that's so
brutal yeah he does have a dagger but
they send that one flying back to Hera
goath hru Castle oh yeah we get this
whole recap mysterious
mmy we just saw this
reanimates we just saw this then Zelda
falls into a and
vanes that must have been when the
castle Rose and the ruins
fell like it's not even a new cut scene
it's just black and white versions of
what we already witnessed 10 minutes
ago maybe a little longer you get the
purad from an unusual
creature no I don't remember Nintendo
ever saying that this was going to be
the darkest Zelda at all that's that's
one of those
typical misinterpretations people have
made
about like all he said was that what
they showed was a little darker than
breath the wild
was but he never said anything about
being darker than Major's mask or
whatever that's just that's just
something people came up with h what
it's very similar to his latest quotes
which apparently have also been taken
out of context it's like oh my God he is
he is totally telling us that the the
old Zelda games are just Nostalgia it's
like no that's that's Japanese is a very
different language you really have
to you know take some time to wait for a
proper
translation which is kind of
disappointing too because then of course
you're going to have YouTubers like Arlo
for example making a video about that
and saying like oh man I'm so
disappointed in what he has to say it's
like you you you could have looked it up
to see that it was taken out of
context but it's I I actually don't even
blame Arlo himself it's just the nature
of YouTube Everything has to be topical
everything has to be fast as soon as
something comes out we have to talk
about it immediately we don't get it any
time to sit there for a little bit at
least at least think about it for a few
days check the sources is this actually
what the man said cuz now anuma is being
vilified for nothing all he said is that
we want to do new things with the
formula we don't want to go back and do
something we've already done before and
yeah that's exactly what Zelda should
always be doing because if we if they
don't it's going to it's going to go the
way of Assassin's Creed you're going to
do the same thing five times over and
then people are going to be sick of it
Zelda always needs to keep doing
completely new things and keep in
Reinventing
themselves or else this series is not
going to have another 20
installments what exactly did he say
though he just said like as far as I'm
aware I'm I'm not even going to pretend
like I speak Japanese or or understand
but I think HMK met a made a pretty good
video about it you can check that one
out but I think he just says like why
would you want to go back to something
you've already done before if you can do
completely new things which yeah I I
think that makes total total
sense like it's the same thing when
people ask me do a life of ablin too
it's like well what am am I what am I
going to do am I just going to do the
exact same thing a second
time like I would actually have to to
have a fun idea a fun little story that
I
can at least do something new with it
you know if I just do the second one but
almost the exact
same it's it's not going to have the
same impact the whole point of that
video was that it came out of left field
and nobody asked for that video and it
was just so
Random like I could have capped a uh
capitalize on it and make another five
life of Life of Carin videos but I'm my
my brain doesn't work that
way HMK is still
relevant uh oh yeah for sure why why
would he not be relevant I mean as a
streamer especially he's
uh he's still doing really really
well aam K is such such a great guy in
real life by the
way cuz I spent quite a bit of time with
him at PAX
East I don't know why I made the the
that circle
around around look at Landing
but that's what happens when I'm
talking I just forget what I'm
doing I adore life of a bin for what
what it is oh yeah thank you
my day has been pretty good pretty
good I walked the dog I did some
work I watched a couple of episodes of
The Outsider and
then I kind of
just chilled oh and I had homemade pizza
that's always good too uh what can I do
here actually I'm I'm just walking
around like a headless chicken at this
point I don't think I really need to do
anything here I think I can just go
to do the regional phenomena right
uh oh no you have to go to the castle
first and then see Phantom Zelda for the
first
time I should put on some clothes
probably I've been running around naked
for the this whole
time I do like look at Landing that's
something tears the kingdom de right
yeah I think Lookout Landing is is a
cool idea this like temporary Fort
although I do find it a bit funny that
this wooden for like isn't it supposed
to be like four or five years later
like couldn't they have built something
a little bit bigger and more fortified
than
this but I like the atmosphere
so and they did change an add to other
towns as well actually I'm quickly going
to head like to the bathroom real quick
so I will be back in about two three
minutes and then we'll go to the castle
or else I'm going to
explode so hang in there I will be right
back uh let me mute the sound real
quick thank you I
will I'll be back in a
moment
and we're back
yeah
okay the hero of
egg eggward
sword excuse me
princess
like obviously the the video that I'm
working on it's not going to be for
everyone because out of the 20 million
people who bought and played TI of the
Kingdom only a small minority are going
to actually care about the story which
you know that's with every game that's
the case you have the general player
base just everyone who played the game
and then you have the people who
actually want to learn more with it more
about the game itself about the
development about the story about the
you know they want to fi find all the
glitches speedrun it th those are always
the minority but
it doesn't make them insignificant
because the people who stick with a game
for longer than just playing it and
moving on to the next game those are the
people who keep those communities alive
and you know I've had so many comments
in the past where people tell me like
because of you I'm so hyped for what we
still knew as breath thew too back then
and it's like yeah that's how it usually
works I get hyped for things because of
other creators a lot of the
time so usually I just ignore the people
who say things like imagine playing
Zelda for the story it's like well yeah
imagine there's there's Decades of
people caring about the story and
theorizing about it and all that kind of
stuff just because it's not the majority
of people who play the game doesn't mean
it doesn't
matter I think you have to talk to that
General
guy which I'm pretty sure he's behind
this wall somewhere
uh I think I think he's up
there imagine playing Zelda for the game
play well yeah that's
uh I think I'm I'm a firm believer that
story is always a good thing to have
even if it doesn't really
matter like would Mario be worse if it
had more complex stories I don't think
so you can have both oh he's not here
wait oh he's on top of the wall over
there I
think that's where he's supposed to be I
think we'll see or or he's up there I
don't know draw distance
man top of the gate house
yeah
there's a very Niche video called tears
of the
kingdom is too much game or something
like that oh I should watch that one
then CU I do think gam playay is leading
in any game uh well almost every game
not not literally every
game
is he here yeah there he there he
is like some games are just interactive
stories like heavy rain or the uh what's
it called until
dawn th those are the type of games
where it the game play is just so
minimal but it doesn't really it's not
about the game play it's about
unraveling a mystery experiencing a
story with slight
interactive elements to
it but yeah for games like Zelda the
first time I played aine of time I
didn't care about the story I was way
too young to understand most of
it but the reason Zelda stuck with me is
because I started learning more about it
and because I got interested in the lore
and you know there's multiple games like
that where I care about the lore a whole
lot but there's also games where I don't
care at all
halflife for example I really really
care about the lore as well I think
halflife lore is so interesting and so
amazing
but I mean the the the game doesn't
really have cutcenes
and even if they are they're they're on
interactive cut scenes you can still
move around you can completely ignore
what people are saying you can just walk
to the other side of the room while
they're
talking
so story for sure is something that
matters in video games just because you
have interactive elements to it doesn't
mean mean you have to ditch one thing
because that's the great thing about
video games is that you can have both
you can tell a story through so many
ways because in a movie you're stuck
with the camera angles and the
information the director wants to tell
you and the writers want to convey you
can only look at a room in the way that
they shot the the the the camera footage
but in video games you get you get to
actually walk around in that room and
you know discover all of its little
secrets within
it that just adds so much that's why
video games have surpassed the video
game or the the the movie industry
nowadays because it's it's
both and there's yeah like you said say
uh Zack wait Z Zack
zerak is that oh no wait that's uh
someone else uh
13 13 13
sorry but yeah that there's many ways to
tell a story a lot of different ways
like I gave the example before like
talking for example he started writing
his stories by drawing a map of the
world first because in his mind you have
to have a clear vision of the world
you're creating first so but that
doesn't mean that's the only way to do
World building or to set up a story
other Writers Do it completely in
completely different ways they might
focus on the
characters like they they might be more
interested in first setting up a
character profile for each important
character in their story there
there's there's a lot of ways to do it
there's no correct way of writing a
story the only thing that does matter is
being consistent with your
story to you know I think Game of
Thrones is the prime is a prime example
of uh them completely failing to keep
consistency because they ran out of
books to cover and then they started
just making up their own stuff and you
know the showrunners were clearly not
they they were not equipped to deal with
that challenge they did not have the
talent for it so characters just
completely change personality all of a
sudden and motivations just completely
are overwritten or don't make any sense
anymore that's the biggest sin in
storytelling is usually consistency if
you're not able to be consistent at
least a little bit then the whole thing
is going to fall
apart consistency and motivation
character motivation is also a thing
that can really ruin a story if if the
characters don't do things that you
would do or are even smarter if you are
so much smarter than the main character
that really hurts the storytelling in in
many ways it's why a lot of horror
movies are stupid because you're just
like no why would you go in there why
would you not call the police why would
you not do this or that and it just it
just annoys
you cuz no rational human being would
act that way they're only doing it
because the story has to go in a certain
direction but they don't know how to
take it into that
direction oh yeah I've been playing
tunic for a little bit so it's it's a
good game it's very difficult it's
deceptively
hard it's just a Souls Souls like mixed
with a little bit of Zelda in there
uh let me see Captain Dog
Doge uh like Metro Prime lets you
completely skip all the lore and
environmental storytelling if you skip
the scan logs but all of it paints a
picture of what you're fighting and U
what you're what you are fighting for if
you read it yeah exactly yeah yeah
yeah like having the option to skip the
lore and not care about it is always a
good thing if you really don't care
about it you should still be able to
enjoy the game
itself like purely from a gameplay uh
perspective but just completely locking
out a part of your fan base and be like
no gam play is all that matters the
story doesn't matter that's just silly
to me
because if you have a good setup for for
lore and you know that a big part of
your fan b or at least a significant
part of your fan base is interested in
that kind of
stuff then why not indulge those people
why not satisfy both camps in
that uh in that
situation oh my voice is really starting
to
go
I have to get some more water
soon yeah someone else mentioned outer
Wilds before about replayability that
not not every game has to have
replayability sometimes it's okay if
it's just one and done in fact in my
humble opinion sometimes that those
types of games tend to have a bigger
Legacy
a better Legacy I guess you could
say I I do think with wels didn't they
make a a cartoon or something to flesh
out the lore a bit
more it was either a cartoon or a manga
or something
I don't remember I haven't finished out
of Wilds just yet I'm
about a few hours in so don't don't
spoil anything for me but so far it's
been really really
amazing is out of Wilds on switch I
don't know I'm I'm playing it on
PC anything that's not a Nintendo first
party or exclusive I usually play it on
PC if it's
available
yeah time to
skydive I wouldn't recommend the switch
version of outer Wells oh there is a
switch
version well I mean if you have better
graphics
and it runs better than
yeah unless you're like all about the
the portability of it then of course
it's a it's a different story I don't
know what the performance of outer Wilds
is
he like if you're on the road a lot and
you just want to play games on the go
then
and obviously the switch version is
always a good
idea congrats on the paraglider at
monster thank
you I was actually kind of confused the
first time I was like wait why didn't I
get the paraglider on the great Sky
Island
before actually speaking of this great
sky island that that's one thing that I
want to uh quickly
address I kind of hear you guys's
thoughts on that
uh so that that's probably going to be
the first point one of the first points
I tackle in my
video is like how raru just
disappears at the end of the great sky
island
but like
he he doesn't share anything with link
even though
when you really think about it he has so
much he could explain to link to make
the adventure more easy for
him he could like if you really think
about all the stuff raru
knows it doesn't make any sense for him
to be that cryptic and just be like yeah
Zelda said exactly this is how you you
would be or something like that and he
just he just disappears and just leaves
you to your own devices it's like he
could have told you so
much which the king of Hyrule in in bre
wild actually did like King Rome is just
straight up like all right here's
everything you need to know at least
everything that I know that happened
back in my time uh and if you want to
learn more you should go to kakaro
Village go to impa she will explain the
final details about what to do and
whatever but here's exactly what what
happened
and raru just doesn't do any of that he
doesn't tell you about Ganondorf like he
could have told you everything about
Ganondorf because that that's he knows
more about Ganondorf than anyone else
pretty
much like that he could have just he was
just holding this guy hostage
underground for for tens of thousands of
years and he doesn't say anything about
it he doesn't say like oh yeah there
used to be this guy in my time his name
is Ganondorf
uh he he like he can tell you some of
his the stuff he did and his motivations
or
whatever but he doesn't tell you
anything and that to me is one of those
moments where you're like do these
characters just want to lose because
they're crippling themselves by not
sharing information with each other that
is that should be
very
logical he I don't think he even says
that Zelda is was in the ancient past
with him he only says like a very he
only says it in a very cryptic way where
like I said he says something like Zelda
says you're exactly as Zelda told me you
would be or something but he doesn't
straight up just say okay look here's
the deal one day she just just showed up
out of nowhere and she's been with us
all this time even helped us fight The
Demon King and blah blah
blah he's just an idiot yeah he's just
dumb
yeah but pretty much everyone in this
game does that it's it's so frustrating
like when you collect the final
memory and you know that Zelda became a
dragon the only person in the whole
world who actually does something with
that or reacts to that that information
is impa impa is I tested this impa is
the only person like you can talk to
anyone in the on the whole planet nobody
will bring it up nobody will be like
wait what you you actually even people
who actively ask about Zelda's
whereabouts like the people from the
newspaper for example or you can go to
Pura you can go to anyone who is
somewhat tied to the main story nobody
link will will not tell anyone about
what he knows only impa is the one who's
like oh she became a dragon damn that's
that's tragic and then she's like anyway
I'm going back to kakaro Village and she
doesn't even inform other people about
it she doesn't even though kakaro
Village is on the way back to or sorry
uh Lookout Landing is is actually on the
way back to krio Village she just she
doesn't even drop by her own sister to
say like hey about this whole search for
Zelda she she became a dragon by the way
it it's so weird how how they manag to
write it that
way because it's finding Zelda is like
the main goal of the whole game for for
the majority of the story it's all about
trying to find out what happened to
Zelda it's not like it's an
insignificant little side plot point or
anything it's literally
the it holds the same weight as destroy
Ganon was in breath of the
wild and nobody shares the information
that they know not even the sages who
were totally there when she transformed
into a dragon you can see them standing
on a cliff
overlooking Zelda as she became a dragon
and went up into the heavens and instead
they just all tell you the the exact
same story about the fight with the
Demon King none of them bring up the
fact that Zelda is a dragon and they
know they totally know that she's a
dragon all this time they
knew and nobody brought it
up there there should not have been a
mystery at
all they could have just called off the
whole search for Zelda and just focus on
different
things
but that you know that's that's kind of
the nature of the whole uh memory system
because if you if you look at breath the
wild the memory system in breath the
wild it even though it's not it was kind
of criticized back then it did make
sense at least
because recovering your memories was a
personal thing for link himself he has
no more memories so it only makes sense
that he goes to specific places to jog
his memory and learn more about what
actually happened to him and to some of
his friends but it's not mandatory to
understand the story you know what I
mean it's it's optional you either
choose to let the past be the past or
you can actually you
know find out more about what happened
exactly yes it's a personal choice
because it's it's his memories but here
you're collecting Zelda's memories and
Zelda's memories contain Vital
Information not just the fact that she
became a dragon but also the fact that
Ganondorf can take on the form of
Zelda like that's something you learn
from the whole cut scene with Sonia when
she gets
killed like you might think that that's
really important information to relay to
your friends because people have been
seeing a weird version of Zelda
everywhere causing trouble and seemingly
not having the best intentions that one
memory changes everything it's like oh
okay so it's not actually Zelda or it
might not at least there's a chance that
it's not actually the real
Zelda but because link cannot interact
interact with other people and share
what he knows because the memories are
optional it doesn't it just doesn't
work
I think the only way they could have
done it better the the only way they
could have solved this problem is to
just have
cutscenes that are actually like you
either play as Zelda in the past or they
just show cutscenes of Zelda in the past
but link doesn't see them so it happens
outside of Link's
own
experience so then in that way we the
audience do know what happened but link
doesn't so so it makes sense that he
doesn't share anything with anyone CU he
doesn't he didn't see what we saw it's a
bit disconnected to between it does kind
of disconnect the player from the from
the character itself but at least it
made his actions more logical let's just
put it that
way link just wants to slap ganor yeah
that's that that's what link does
yeah
yeah it is it is definitely foreshadowed
that Zelda turns into a dragon I I
figured it out the moment she was
talking to minu and I think most people
did the moment she says like oh to be a
dragon is to Lose Yourself you can as as
as soon as she uh spells out the the the
fact that you can swallow a tier and
turn into a dragon I think most people
put two and two together and we're like
okay yeah she she's totally going to
become a dragon but like the the actual
execution of it was really really well
done I I think I think they really did a
good job with that with the
transformation cut
scene I remember really being moved by
by that cutscene the first time I played
it got a got a got a little bit te eyed
when I saw that just the way she
clutches onto the master sword and you
can see how fearful she is for about
what what's about to happen to her body
but she knows it's the only way
and then you see the eyes change and she
does that little like protect protect
them all I think she
says uh it was really really well done
that's why I said you can love certain
set pieces in this story but also be
critical of the way the story is
told yeah protect them all that that's
uh
but I think that's kind of a thing with
a lot of people and I cannot really
blame people for that like people often
mistake set pieces for story but a set
piece is just the way you communicate
something through a
certain through the visuals
and but it doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with the writing of the
the core
narrative and I think that's where most
of my problems with this story lie it's
not necessarily all the sto the like the
set pieces or the the characters it's
more about how they put the whole story
together and how it just falls apart as
soon as you start
to think a little bit more about it
which is the opposite of many other
stories that I know that I do like a lot
is the more I think about those stories
the better it
gets hey pixel Fusion
I'm just going to run past this guy I
have to quickly I'm just going straight
for the story
stuff I think we can just do another
stream next
week like maybe somewhere Midway next
week and then another way another one in
the weekend because it it does help to
just vent my thoughts and just talk
about it
here and plus I can capture
footage I think it's fun plus it kind of
makes up for the lack of videos in the
coming weeks
because like I said this is going to be
the longest video I've ever done it's
going to be at least 1 hour to one and a
half hour long because there's so much
to talk about and I I don't want to I
don't want to skip any uh anything I
want to make sure
I substantiate all my Grievances and
claims
and do it in a fair way you
know you know there there's always there
there are people who are going to it's
going to be a divisive video anyway like
it's not like I can change
that people are very passionate
about this series in general and not
everyone can take criticism as well
others like the people I I tend to
respect the most s of people that
disagree with me but they do it in such
a respectful way they're like hey man I
I don't agree at all with you because of
so and so but I still I think it was
worth hearing you hearing you out and
you do make some good points or whatever
those are the people people I can
really because it's it's hard it's very
difficult to disagree with someone about
something that's that you're passionate
about like I've had moments like that
before where I'm I'm totally crazy about
something and I I really love it in in
every single way and someone just tears
it apart and I'm like man you
bastard why would you ruin it for
me which by the way is not the intention
of my video obviously I'm not going to
the goal is not to make people angry or
try to ruin the fun for
them but I do think it's worth exploring
why people didn't
like all parts of this
story does he have a red spot on his
elbow where did that come
from it's like me when I've been leaning
on my my my table for too long holding
my mouse I will have one of those red
spots on my
elbow to you uh let's see J JRR talki to
your knowledge what do you think is the
best told most complete most coherent
story books video games myths Etc oh
that's a that's a hard one I I
previously mentioned dark which is
probably one of the best time travel
stories ever made if not the best I
think it's the
best there's really nothing I can find
about that story where I'm like that
doesn't make any sense it all fits
together so
well but I I don't really I don't
necessarily believe anything is perfect
so like I'm I'm huge on Lord of the
Rings obviously just the way he fleshed
out his Universe the universe of Middle
Earth
is is is
just it it's it's crazy how one man can
do
that but you know that isn't to say that
everything talking did made sense some
he he read con some stuff for a reason
you know he realized himself that some
parts of what he wrote didn't
really fit with other works or you know
like The Hobbit for
example was kind of red con oh Fu [__]
no oh I forgot to bring her on
board oh she already corrects
me but yeah it's very difficult to say
like the best most cohesive
story
oh usually stories that just end at some
point though those are those tend to be
the best ones normally when the longer
something continues to go on the harder
it it becomes to to to keep the whole
thing
together like I think Breaking Bad is
really good because it just stopped
After Five Seasons when it didn't
overstay it's
welcome okay let's
go
uh do you think the Zelda movie will be
good
uh I I've already addressed that before
I I'm cautiously
optimistic it's hard to say right now
because I haven't seen
anything we we only have an announcement
so there's no footage there's no cast
there's nothing but I'm I'm cautiously
optimistic because I do like the
director
and I think he has what it takes to make
it work at
least my favorite game franchise is
Kingdom Hearts and the story is a
complete
mess I I do hear that sometimes
yeah well I mean at least you you're
able to acknowledge
that
I mean the Zelda Timeline is a complete
mess too when you
really sit down and analyze how it all
works like the whole Fallen Hero
timeline the the the downfall timeline
doesn't make any sense at
all but it doesn't matter like I've I've
never put that much weight on the
timeline to begin
with i as a Zelda theorist you kind of
have to acknowledge its existence and
play with with it once in a while and it
it is fun to sometimes do a theory and
that heavily incorporates the the whole
timeline
stuff but to to say that it's all like
well we finally did it it's it's a it's
one perfect little package no not even
not even
close and I think Nintendo uh kind of
floats in the middle of that
too like they don't really want to
commit to a giant linear story that just
keeps following up on that on itself but
they also don't want to let go of the
continuity part of it either they don't
want to just make a game that's
completely on its
own that they will try their best to
make it function as as its own thing so
that new players can pick up any Zelda
game and still understand at least what
they're doing
but they also
still they they they don't really want
to make a
choice you can either go the the
souls Souls born route and just have
like you know Dark Souls
bloodborne uh Seco they're all confirmed
to be disconnected they're all the the
creators themselves have have made it
very clear like Dark Souls does follow
up on itself like uh two is a little bit
iffy
but Dark Souls 1 and three at least they
they they do uh they they they are in
the same universe and I'm guessing two
as
well but Elden ring and and
and and bloodborne uh bloodborne and
stuff they they've made it very clear
like don't even try to connect those
games because they're not connected
they're they're different universes
different
stories and at least then you you know
what you're getting you
know but yeah Nintendo doesn't really
want to do that with Zelda just straight
up
just either go with a connected universe
or just have separate stories that don't
matter
in like it doesn't
matter like which game you play first
because they're not really connected to
each
other oh see you later egg thank you for
for uh dropping by it's been
fun I think I will just uh do another
stream on Wednesday something like that
Wednesday
Thursday and then another one on
Saturday
Sunday either of those too depending on
my
schedule uh can I just build a bridge
across here I think I
can still doing that black screen thing
it's very
annoying I don't remember being this
pool of water being around the tower
five years ago yeah some things did
change maybe they had very very heavy
rainfall
oh no the tree is in the
way nailed
it actually I should probably line that
one up
too will it reach or will it just float
in the
water
no I think it
will
yeah there we go I'm not sure if that's
how you're supposed to do it
[Music]
but what do you think of VR get games uh
they kind of make me nauseous which is a
shame because I really want to play
halflife Alex I've seen a playthrough of
it because I wanted to know where the
story is going but to actually
experience it myself would be very nice
but I don't know if I could handle it
maybe with Alex I could CU it's been a
while since I last played a VR
game so maybe they've improved the
visuals or the frame rate or something
to make it get a little less
jarring but yeah like after even after
like 10 minutes it really started to
make me feel
disoriented and my eyes started to hurt
a little
bit see you around pixel
Fusion thank you so much for dropping
by oh hey
Don
Jer
uh the Metroid games are not perfect in
terms of consistency but they still
probably they're still probably the most
coherent lore heavy Nintendo
series while still having games to
explore different ideas yeah I need to
get into Metroid lore a bit
more
uh carit OD says for me personally I
find it to be a healthy mindset not to
be attached to anything or ever get my
hopes up too high the world is isn't
built for my pleasure yeah that's true
that's
true the only thing I I do feel like uh
I do feel it's it's good to criticize
the things you love cuz that's how you
move forward that's how progress is made
even if the the criticism isn't
necessarily for the better we can at
least explore why we don't like certain
things or don't like
or you know what I
mean like if you're only going to sing
thing uh sing the praise of things
you're not going to move forward because
then pretty much every Zelda game is
just a the perfect game ever and it it
there is no progress it's either going
to be all the the best or all the
worst that's why I like videos like the
ones from from Joseph Anderson and King
K and like yeah I I might disagree with
80% of the whole video but they also
make some really valid points in my
opinion where I'm like yeah I I think
they should do that better in fact one
of my favorite quotes
from those guys is from King K when he
says uh every Zelda game is universally
praised and or universally reviewed very
well and I think that's a mistake and I
feel like he's on to something there
because if you only praise Nintendo for
what you're
getting then there's no moving forward
anymore we're just going to be Pokemon
fans at the end of the day just pick up
every game play it out of obligation to
the series and then nothing's ever going
to
change whereas if you criticize
things you that's when you get changes
that's when you go
from like Wind Waker to Twilight
Princess because people even though they
did like Wind Waker they were also like
well we we do miss the more serious tone
of the
of the previous games a bit and there
wasn't enough Dungeons and you know lo
and behold the twilight princess has
like tripled the amount of dungeons or
double something like
that yeah I'm at my Oak
down yeah a mix of both
man like breath to while when that game
first came out we were so so so hyped
for that game we are we were having so
much fun with
it po Pokemon gets worse and fans still
buy the games and not and don't complain
yeah and it's fine if you're happy with
what what they present to you that's
totally fine but don't don't get on
get on to people or call them haters
just because they're like you know maybe
you should you we should be asking for
more it's like the biggest franchise on
the planet they have all the money they
have infinite
money and
yet they're not it doesn't really show
in the production value
or it's just weird to me how you're so
willing to just give yourself over to a
to a company like
that not not saying that you're like
obligate that any any company or
actually no company is obligated to do
anything they can do whatever they want
but that doesn't mean we have to like
it like uh I'll I'll give you an example
of some something that's completely
unrelated to uh video games so that's
not something that not a lot of people
know about me but like uh one of my
biggest Hobbies beside video games is
air gunning uh and paintball paintball
and air gunning it's it's not the same
thing but it's you know it's both you
both work with high-pressured air
systems and all that
stuff and they are expensive Hobbies if
you really get into to it you know you
you can buy a paintball gun for like uh
bucks maybe 300 if you want a complete
outfit with with you know a mask and all
that kind of
stuff uh but if you really want
something good and be able to compete
then you're going to have to spend a lot
more because obviously not all guns like
air guns are made
equal but the problem with air guns in
general is that they are so so the
manufacturers of air guns are so lazy
like it takes years for things to
develop it takes years for spare parts
to come along and air guns break all the
[__] like all the freaking
time like you constantly have to deal
with leaks and uh they keep uh like
ruining all kinds of features on them
and like you spend a thousand bucks on
something and it just breaks after a
week and you're like God damn it why can
not why can not one of these companies
just get it right for for a change
there's always something wrong with
these
things mon air gunning is just uh like
shooting targets but with air guns
instead of firearms cuz you know
Firearms where I live is not
really it's not really a what it is
allowed but you need to get a license
and it's it's it's a it's a
pain you know getting a license is not
the issue it's that like if you want to
own a firearm in in the Netherlands
you're basically inviting the police to
come to your house without a warrant
twice or once or twice per year and they
just get to inspect your your weapons
and your cuz there's very strict rules
when it comes to keeping your weapon
locked up here uh the people who do have
a firearm certificate and they go to
shooting ranges and all that
stuff they uh you have to keep your gun
like in a
safe and you have to keep the ammunition
in a separate safe and those two safes
have to be like a certain distance from
each other or something like that so you
cannot make any rash decisions or I'm
pretty sure it's also for the safety of
children and if you have kids you know
which you know I don't think is a Bad
Thing necessarily but you know the only
way to enforce that law is for the
police to just come by your house
unannounced twice per year and just be
like all right show us where the guns
are and a lot of people just that does
that's too much for most people to deal
with and you don't have that problem
with air guns air guns are just free as
long as you're 18 plus you're you can
just go out and buy one doesn't matter
how powerful it is or how dangerous they
are that you can just buy one
and actually Airsoft is the opposite for
Airsoft you also have to get a license
it's not as strict I think I don't think
the police come to your house to check
up on your airsoft gun uh guns as far as
I
know
but but anyway the the point I was
making is that air Gunners in general
are very
easily contempt with what these
companies are doing to them even though
we should be demanding more and it
annoys the hell out of me whenever I
bring like for example there was a story
about one air gun specific brand of air
gun that I own
personally and it
exploded like
someone's someone's air gun actually
blew up and almost took out like half of
their face as I think they were unharmed
by some weird Stroke of Luck they were
not uh they they weren't
hurt but but I mean still you know
that's a 300 Bars of pressure right next
to your face exploding that's a major
design flaw and people were so easy to
just be like well it's probably just a
oneoff and the you know the company was
basically investigating itself you're
like yeah we're going to check to see if
what we did if the the material is
actually safe and blah blah blah it's
like the government investigating itself
like yeah that we we concluded that we
did nothing wrong it's
like just everything about the quality
of of of of air guns the the the
mistakes that these manufacturers make
people are just so easy to brush them
off as and just accept what these
companies are spoon feeding you and I
think the same thing goes for video
games is we always have to demand the
best because you're paying 60 bucks
that's
no like I don't know about you but I'm
I'm I invest hundreds of bucks per year
into video games just buying all kinds
of different games so when a when a
cyberpunk comes along yeah like yeah
everybody is unanimous unanimously going
to be like okay you guys really screwed
up but I think we should do that with
every game in
general like that's how Innovation Works
right like imagine if we never criticize
Nintendo for the the way they use the
iron boots or something in in AR enough
time maybe they would still be doing the
same thing now who
knows well you need a firearm license
yeah kind of like that yeah I don't want
to get too much off topic it's just a
fun little thing that I like a little
anecdote that I suddenly thought of
because I I literally had a discussion
like that a few days
ago
where people were just like well you
know the company is doing their best
it's like no they're not they're not
doing their best at
all complaining is a good thing in
general like ratosa you should have been
you should be Dutch actually Dutch
people are known for complaining about
everything that's why our infrastructure
is so good because everything we we
don't just complain about it we fix it
afterwards we're never satisfied if the
train is 5 minutes late we're going to
start
riots so yeah like for example Nintendo
switch online if it's really
subar we shouldn't buy it just buy it or
be like or make up excuses for Nintendo
as to why it's subar it's like no they
should do better as a
company we shouldn't just let them spoon
feed everything
we uh like yeah well you know what I
mean I'm I'm getting it's getting harder
to speak for me my voice is really
starting to
go you guys are getting trains yeah
exactly now the D the the Dutch are
famous for
it I actually wanted to use revali's Gil
just now to get over to those
clips it's still burnt into my into my
system see if I can hit the flag
pole
yes America should do should be more
like that yeah I guess so well if you
want things to change you have to
complain a lot or else things stay the
same and you know sometimes it can be to
your own DET detriment a little bit like
uh when I went to Holiday uh to uh I
went on holiday to
kurasa one of the islands down south
from
America and uh like things on kurosa
never change like ever if you visit
there one year and there's a car wreck
aside like standing aside on the side of
the road somewhere if you come back 5
years later that same car wreck is still
going to be
there like people just don't care about
anything there they're so relaxed and so
laid back
and like it's it's there's no change at
all or at least very little
change and then there's me this worked
up Dutch guy coming over there I'm like
immediately I start complaining about
everything I'm like why is there no
public transport why don't they just
create a tram that go like the the the
island is only two kilometers wide uh
like at its Center why don't they just
make like a a tram that goes across the
island in in an oval shape like in a
circle you could hit every important
location like immediately just start
going off the rail about everything they
could improve or change and meanwhile
these people just they they're they're
like no we'll just drive the car it's
it's all
fine
uh the island itself is called kurasa
it's one of the three uh ABC islands I I
think they called them Aruba boner and
kurasa like it's it's just funny because
people uh the people who uh they are
also Dutch but they've been living there
for years and they've accept they've
integrated into their into that society
and they just kind of had to laugh about
it they're like you are so typical Dutch
where you're just coming in here
thinking you like immediately coming up
with all kinds of solutions about what
should change and what should be
improved and trust me it's not going to
happen just give up just accept that
this is how it
is people in the UK complain but do
nothing about it well yeah
that's I I guess that would be
counterproductive well I mean not
everyone who complains here is helping
to change things we just let the
government do it we're just like hey
man we don't like this change it
now and sometimes they do sometimes they
don't wait where am I going I'm
completely turned around I think oh
there it is and now I lost all my
stamina damn it have to go back
anyway I think you just have to find a a
healthy balance when it comes to
complaining or because at the same time
I'm also very easily
entertained I'm not the type who goes to
a movie and then just while I'm watching
the movie can pick out all the plot
points or all the the plot holes or
usually that that that's not how my my
brain works I'm I'm easily entertained
in in
general and I think that's a good thing
too
sometimes because if you're just going
to be picking things apart your whole
life you're gonna have a very hard time
enjoying anything basically because
everything made by human beings is going
to be flawed to some degree you
know it's just that on YouTube
negativity sells very very well I would
say it sells better than
positivity
overall like that's why channels like
the critical Drinker and stuff like that
they're so
popular because people like to hear
people other people burn things to the
ground and it's sometimes it's a bit sad
to
me that's why I'm only going to do one
video about the story of Tears the
kingdom just get it out all out of my
system the whole like all my complaints
everything I I don't like about it I'm
just going to try to tackle every one of
them wrap it up into one cohesive little
package and then hopefully at least and
then uh I'm going to just move on to
other things be it Zelda theories
or news or you know maybe pick up some
Elden ring lore again once the DLC
drops
cuz I I I don't want to do that I I have
nothing to gain from complaining about
Zelda all day or criticizing it all day
because it it is still my favorite
series and
the the the story is not going to my my
gripes with the story is not going to
change
that is that
as long as we can have a healthy
discussion about
it that's all that really
matters it's tuling the only Sage who
matters at least in terms of abilities
he
does he's the only Sage I have
permanently
well semi-permanently
on I like his
ability
also by the way thanks for dropping by
rat Oscar it's always always a
pleasure yeah exactly I do feel the kind
of the same way about it like I don't
think I will be doing my own audience
any like I I think I would be doing
people at this service if I tend like I
do like the story or just ignore how I
feel because that's not something I can
change you either like something or you
don't and I I've given it enough time I
feel to settle down a bit because you
know I wasn't going to make a video like
that like a month after release because
things can grow on you things can change
things can you know with subsequent uh
subsequent playthroughs with some deeper
thought having discussions with other
people and giving uh getting different
perspectives on it sometimes things
change but you know it's been we're
getting close to a
year and it's only gotten worse to be
honest
I really did give it a fair chance I I
can tell you that for
sure but it is what it
is what OST do you
prefer uh what do you mean breath of
wild and this between breath the Wild
and this one
because I think both are pretty much
similar obviously there's a lot of uh
recycling in the music department but
that that's understandable I like the
the
atmosphere of the music and I'm still
convinced that it's better that the the
game does not have Overworld music not
with a a world this
size did it just I don't think it would
work but there there's there's a few
definitely a few bangers in here that
are completely new
and which I really
like I think the uh all the dungeon
music is really
good uh the main theme obviously is very
very
good uh the Zora Waterworks is
extremely uh atmospheric and very good
for videos because it's like kind of
like has that calm
atmosphere same goes for the uh what's
it called the construct Factory
music new zeld that content creators
should stop hating on a game you make
money of oh so should we should just
pretend to like something we don't and
be complete
disingenuous
people just be nintend
Bots just thank you Nintendo for giving
us this this great game
we we we have no no complaints no
wishes sorry that just doesn't fly from
me
man i' I've said this
before having critiques doesn't mean you
hate something
I don't hate this
game I don't hate a lot of things
actually the story is just something I
do not
enjoy it's not something that resonates
with
me I'd rather be honest than to sell out
to some kind of
Nintendo like some of those people who
are like Nintendo ambassadors not all
them of course but some of them I do
have a hard time taking their opinions
about things seriously because you know
as soon as you get in bed with a company
obviously you are going to be biased in
some way which is I would never ever
want to work with Nintendo in any
capacity I want to do whatever I want I
want I don't want to be tied to them I
don't care if they never give me a
preview for a preview playthrough of a
Zelda game I I really couldn't care less
I just want to be creative and do my own
things I don't know where I should go
I'm just running around like an idiot
again I think I'll just go up to the
mountain then because that's where the
next story element takes place or we
could just go for all
the for all the memories but I don't
think we have time it's already 11
here probably have to go to bed
soon or else my brain is going to be
buzzing I I won't be able to
sleep yeah Nintendo does deserve more
criticism but also the
praise the praise they get is definitely
earned they they are one of the most
consistent most creative developers out
there but obviously they're also doing
stuff wrong they're a little bit out of
touch sometimes with their own with
their own
audience they make some pretty nasty
business decisions I actually had a
script written for a video called why
Nintendo is the worst company ever and
also the best but I never finished it
because I I think other stuff got in the
way or I I kind of changed my mind where
I was like ah I don't want to talk about
company [__] right
now but it was basically about that
about how Nintendo is just this weird
contradiction it's a living
contradiction like they're very
kid-friendly but they're also one of the
most vicious companies out there a bit
like Disney you know with all their
takedowns and the way they go after
people who mod stuff and they just don't
always want to suck the fun out of all
like out of fan fan initiative
basically like they make some of the
best games in the
industry but they also do some really
really wacky stuff with some of their
IPs what was the main point uh basically
that
just like it was supposed to be I think
it was around the time Nintendo started
messing with the smash Community that's
what kind of motivated me into writing
that script
because Nintendo has been absent from
the smash Community for pretty much all
of its existence like it was Grassroots
it was it was started by passionate
people and we didn't care or the people
who started the whole thing they didn't
care that the game wasn't supposed to be
a competitive game that it was supposed
to be kind of like a party game at the
time time they were like no no the these
mechanics are so deep and so cool
whether it's an accident or not this
could be one of the best competitive
games ever one of the best competitive
fighting games ever and lo and behold
they were right like the through pure
like perseverance they managed to get
into Evo and
then get in get on the the pro circuit
it's one of the most popular fighting
games to
watch
and now all of a sudden Nintendo wants a
piece of the pie and comes in and starts
demanding people get streaming licenses
and like starts meddling with all these
T tournament organizers they they've
never done anything to help this
community ever they've never sponsored
them they never gave them any help
developer notes even even simple stuff
like patch notes was too much to ask for
we always had to get in there get into
the source code and and or or just te
like into a testing ground or like a
testing level and just figure out all
the changes that they made like even
that was too much to
ask and now all of a sudden they're
starting to interject and and force
themselves into this community it's like
[__] off go away you you've had your
chance to embrace this
community just leave people alone
please
like it doesn't matter that they own the
IP what we do with our games after the
game comes out that's our business like
if I want to host a Smash Brothers
tournament in my basement do I have to
get a license from Nintendo because
technically I'm gathering people I could
even charge them for
entering five bucks to to to enter the
the the tournament in my
basement
like does the inventor of the tennis
racket have a say in what goes on in
tennis
competitions for the rest of their life
no like the game is out there we've all
bought it they've made millions and
millions and millions on
it and what we do in our spare time or
whether it's speedr running or holding
competitions that's not something a
company should be able to dictate I'm
think we should have the freedom to do
whatever we we want with it aside from
obviously selling
it like making big money on uh boot
lagging or
whatever that that's that's one thing
that I do feel like that's going a step
too far oh my God it's Resident Evil
what what do what do I
do
no almost got cut into
ribbons for bathroom fee yeah yeah
yeah like obviously if you're going to
me be making your own remake of a of
time and then selling it like charging
60 bucks for it yeah that obviously
that's illegal you you cannot just do
that because then you are taking someone
else's IP and literally selling it
remaking it in Unreal Engine for Unreal
Engine in
general but holding tournaments and
stuff I don't know man tournaments are
run by sponsorships in general and entry
fees you're not really selling a product
you're selling the
experience but I I guess that's where
the video kind of came from I was very
pissed at the time about the stuff
Nintendo was doing to the smash
Community but I I never went through
with that video cuz I don't
know I wanted to talk about Zelda
instead cuz that was before tears of the
Kingdom's uh
release
oh do you think the next Zelda will be
VR it kind of depends on what the switch
two will be I
[Music]
think like if the switch 2 has VR
capabilities or whatever
maybe maybe maybe they do see the
potential Nintendo I guess Nintendo
would be the type of company that sees
that type of technology and it's like
yeah I think we're ready to take it to
the next level I don't
know in that way they're kind of similar
to valve valve only does things when
they can
innovate I've never been able to wrap my
my head around lore wise as to why there
are puzzles Within These shrines uh I
have not either and I have
tried cuz there are supposed to be like
seals right there
like I think uh they said like every
Shrine is a place where demon was
defeated and they're keeping evil at
Bay it's like at least with the shrines
in breath the wild it made sense why
they had puzzles and challenges and
stuff inside because it was it was all
made for the hero
specifically it's a very over engineered
plan but it's it at least it made sense
from a from a lore perspective kind of
here it's just like there's just a
puzzle inside and
I I I have no idea
why uh do you think we'll we will have
any news of the switch to in the next
two to three months oh I I am not the
guy to ask about that man
I'm like people have been bringing up
switch Pro switch 2 for such a long time
I'm I'm just so incredibly tired of it
I'm like it'll be here when it when it's
here when when they're ready
ow as I get clobbered in the
face but yeah I I I I have no idea I
have no predictions for it it could take
up to a year maybe
even it could be next month or at the
end of this month whenever the next
direct will
be
I do hope so because the switch has kind
of even though it's still running strong
like going strong it's it has run its
course for me personally I think graphic
wise Graphics wise
and performance wise I think it does
need an upgrade now it's been it's been
six years or something seven
almost
switch 2 is a Next Generation system
that is
inevitable switch Pro is just a mid
generation yeah yeah I know I I agree it
is it is coming for sure and whatever it
will be there will be a successor to the
switch obviously it's just that people
have been making predictions about it
for such a long time now in when it
comes to new hardware uh new hardware
people have
been they've just been wrong in like on
so many levels every time
like I've been burned too many times
where people seem to be so confident
about what they knew about the switch
and what Nintendo is doing with their
Hardware where I'm like yeah I'll just
sit back and when it when it
arrives it arrives and I'll I'll I'll
get
it for
sure I'm just not not holding my breath
for it not
yet whatever it is I hope it's not Wii U
to no probably
not I think that was the biggest mistake
they've ever made Hardware wise so I
don't think they will be doing that
again anytime
soon oh wait Tulin is still inside that
cave thing right or can I just go up
there I think I can just go up there
right
yeah this part is probably the coolest
run up to all of like the the coolest
lead up to any of the dungeons just
climbing this huge stairway of islands
is really
cool and then diving into the eye of the
Storm at at the
top they are birds they are indeed
which kind of makes you wonder why they
stick around
uh reto Village when it's all frozen
over they're like oh no what we what can
we do our village like well you can just
fly to a warmer place for the time being
even if it's just temporarily your birds
come
on just fly the Lookout Landing just
hold up there for for a little
while until the storm blows over over
it's not like you're going to
die people still hang around hang around
uh the village in the
meantime go to the quest mark I think
it's up here right I remember you can
just trigger
it Monster M do a video about the light
Spirits in Twilight
Princess sure
I I'm not sure what it would be about
aside from they
exist but I do want to do more Twilight
Princess
stuff cuz I like Twilight Princess I do
have a video
planned for the
future about the let's see I still have
the I I think it's one of the few
few uh videos where I already have a
thumbnail for it normally I do the
thumbnail at the end based on you know
if I use 3D artwork I will do that like
obviously at the at the very end
so uh let me see let me see let me
see if it's still
here
[Music]
uh yeah the hero
shade there we
go I think it's a pretty cool
thumbnail but yeah it's it's basically
going to be about some of the stuff he
did before he presumably
died because people tend to focus on oh
it's the hero of Time how did he die who
did he end up with to have Offspring in
the in in in the in the first place but
there's so much more to his story that
you can kind of unravel when you really
think about like his transformation into
a wolf the the howling Stones how he
apparently set those up for for the
future his future
Offspring I think there's a lot to
explore there just make a
nice nice video about
it but obviously tears of the Kingdom
content got a lot
of uh
priority because I made that thumbnail
before the game was out
so uh spiky
spear it did not load the graphic of the
spike well by
how did Ganondorf
have in Twilight Princess have the
Triforce if he was arrested in a child
timeline well that's why it's called the
Divine prank right nobody really knows
why he suddenly had the Triforce of
power it's something people have been
theorizing about for a while
it's like almost as if the gods are
trying
to I don't know like create equal
opportunities or
something because we know Zelda has the
Triforce of wisdom and Link has the
Triforce of
Courage so someone has to have power
like link has it on his hands from the
very
beginning or on his hand I should say he
has like the Triforce tattoo on his
on the back of his
hand goddess troll yeah
yeah who knows man what I don't even
want to pretend like I know how Gods
would
think they are so far beyond like above
us it's like love crafti and stuff right
there yeah it's still having the black
screen problem I don't know why I have
no idea why it does
that I guess you really do have to get
Tulin bow first I thought I remember
coming up here and something triggered
maybe was just this
guy okay I'll go to your stupid
objective
marker tears of the
Kingdom which means I'm going to have to
make this whole CL all over again but
that's my
bad I'm not playing at 480p I should be
streaming in
1080P is he up
there like this is where you fight the
dudes to get his bow back
I know
that I'll just go to the glowy dot on
the on the
map oh it is 1080p
okay so someone is blaming me for their
own poor
internet
I feel like YouTube has been a bit
inconsistent in that way sometimes it
will just randomly jump to 480p as the
default I'm like I have super fast
internet what are you talking about why
would I want
that oh no did I just totally screw
myself it's way further
actually I'm probably going to call it
quit
soon it's really starting to get late
got to keep my sleeping schedule healthy
so I think I'll just uh do another
stream somewhere oh well there we go oh
we're back uh but yeah I'll just do
another stream in the midweek next week
and then another one in the
weekend and in the meantime I'm just
going to continue to write my script get
my thoughts on
paper and then hopefully somewhere at
the beginning of February or half like
halfway through February at at the
latest I will be able to upload the
video I think the script this time is
going to be the hardest part uh because
editing and visuals I I don't really
have to worry too much about that I can
just use mostly use gameplay and and
cutcenes and I don't have to animate
things or so the the it's mostly going
to be how I am able to word this in the
best way I can uh which is why I said in
the community post it's going to be a
nice challenge for my script writing
skills and of course recording the voice
over is going to be a it's going to be a
bit of a nightmare for me if it's going
to be an hour one and a half hours
long then
yeah
no tears of the Kingdom did not ruin the
franchise even if you really really
really dislike this game in every let's
say you you dislike everything about it
even the game play not just the story
it's still just one out of 20 games and
there's going to be more games after
this like
one I've said this before there's
there's been Zelda games in the past
that I really did not like I did not
like Phantom Hourglass at
all I kind of hated it in the beginning
did it ruin the franchise for me no obv
obviously not because there's always
going to be the next game and TW uh I
think Spirit Tracks was already a big
step up from Phantom
Hourglass same goes for Skyward Sword I
really did not like Skyward Sword when
it first came out like at all
did it ruin the franchise for me nah not
even
close it's a bit overdramatic to say
that something ruins a
franchise like you would really have to
go out of your way to ruin Zelda that
they would have to have at least like a
few big big failures in order to
conclude like yeah okay they Zelda has
fallen from grace and you know if that
day ever does come so be
it but right now I don't see any signs
of that happening like bre the wild just
re like revitalized the
series it's been nominate nominated for
game of the
year uh like both breath of wild and
tears of the kingdom and breath of wild
actually ended up winning
it like you cannot go to one of the the
most successful like the first I think
it's the first game to surpass ARF time
at least in terms of popularity and and
sales and then immediately have an
entire franchise ruined
because the sequel doesn't really live
up to
expectations but you
know I will say it's been very difficult
to make lore videos now
yeah like there's a reason why you why
you see other creators going back to
other Zelda games already even though
it's not even been a year since tear of
the Kingdom came out it's because
there's just not a whole lot to work
with they just did not focus on the
environmental storytelling and the main
story is pretty clearcut it has a clear
beginning middle and end there's not a
whole lot of mystery left there either
and we're probably not going to get a
book like creating a champion so yeah
it's it's not going to be as easy to be
a Zelda lore YouTuber right now I'll
give you that for
sure well I mean tears of the Kingdom
did bring other things to the table it
brought brand new abilities that were
really really well done and I would say
evolutionized game
design there's a reason why so many game
designers have been like what the hell
did Nintendo do with these physics it's
insane how they are able to do this kind
of
stuff a game can bring things to the
table in other ways it just didn't bring
things uh it just didn't bring a whole
lot of things to the table
story-wise like it only made things more
confusing in some ways
hey you know it's uh it's time is coming
I will be
covering all that I don't like about
it but it didn't ruin the the franchise
for
me not even close I mean I still enjoyed
playing game in
general just going to make my job a
little bit harder which is probably why
I'm going to have to I guess focus on
other games not just other Zelda games
but also just other franchises once in a
while
maybe delve into some other topical
stuff I I I don't know I'm still
figuring that out I'm still trying to
uh I'm still trying to figure out where
where my channel is going after this cuz
I'm not going to be able to make up lore
videos for the next three
years just about this game alone that's
not going to be doable I can barely do
it now and it's not even been a year and
trust me I really really am
trying but most of the stuff that really
interested me some of the lore that I
did find interesting in this game like
some of the stuff in the depths and the
how the seal works and those have
already been covered by both myself and
others so
yeah well you know that's fine uh this
game was not created to satisfy my CH my
my Zelda Niche Little Zelda lore
Channel I'll just have to be creative
and think to think about other other
stuff
that I can
cover which you know I'm sure I'm sure I
can yeah Metroid for example or some
non- Nintendo stuff once in a while
would also be fun we have Elden ring DLC
coming
up well they've always designed Zelda
games with uh the gameplay in mind first
and then story second or even like at
the very very end they kind of
just fit it all together into a little
bit of a story thingy but it worked at
least well
enough I think most Zelda stories are
you know they're sufficient enough and
they work some of some I would argue are
even really really
great like especially Wind Waker and
Twilight Princess had just good stories
Good
characters so they they can do it we
know they they can do it even if it's an
afterthought they can still get it done
because afterthoughts are not always
like an excuse that they cannot always
be used as an excuse for well if it's
bad that's just because it's an
afterthought it's like many of the
things in my videos are afterthoughts
and sometimes it it ends up being the
best part of the video like my last
video where I have that part where the
the the rat is dancing that was done at
the very very end where I was like I
need one more joke to tie this whole
thing together just to make it a little
more fun and it ended up being the most
referenced part of the video in the
comment section because it just it just
I
guess I it hit the right
notes any possibility you might move on
to genin impact it's similar to bre wild
cough cough
and there's more content in for in terms
of lore I might give it a
chance uh I don't really like gacha
games I think they're a little bit
predatory I guess you could say
but I
mean I could talk to Nintendo black
crisis he knows more about the the game
and about the lore than I
do but some of the stuff he told me
about how much money some people spend
on that game is insane to
me like if I would cover it I would only
purely like I would only cover the stuff
that I know is important to the lore but
if you want to be a genchan YouTuber I
think you have to spend like so much
money to just get everything so you you
have all the details and all the
characters and all the all the lore and
I'm not willing to do
that
but maybe I'll do a video about it
sometime maybe I'll do a comparison
video between breath the Wild and uh and
genin sometime and yes not tears of the
kingdom and genin because that's not
fair because it's the
sequel I just want to cover things that
interest me in in
general like I've always wanted to do a
halflife video at some point I've always
wanted
do uh
fallout at some point at least something
I I definitely want to do a video about
environmental storytelling in general
not just in Zelda games but in
games like yeah I know game maker
toolkit has done has done something like
that but I think I can make
something that's more my own cuz I
recently played like the only other game
I played this year besides outer wilds
and just my typical Counter Strike like
I I sometimes just pop counter- strike
on play a couple of rounds and then go
go back to work but aside from that the
only other game I played this year was
Starfield and I was really looking
forward to Starfield and it disappointed
me so so much because it kind of has the
same problem as tears of the Kingdom
except TI of the Kingdom at least has
good gameplay and like Starfield has
neither it it has a horrible story no
environmental storytelling or
interesting lore whatsoever like
everything is just the same buildings
copy pasted across all the planets most
most of the time like all the stuff that
I love about Bethesda games
normally like all the cool stuff that
you can find in the world and stuff that
that's just absent from from the game
and it doesn't have Vats so it's not
even like even gameplay-wise it's just a
typical generic
shooter so yeah Starfield was a
bust there's still so much great Zelda
content to cover I would love to see
some more Major's mask and Wind Waker oh
yeah for sure for sure which is what you
will probably see more and more from
other creators as well as myself is just
going back back to other games a bit
more cuz I
think the pool of lore that we can get
into when it comes to tears of the
Kingdom it's going to get exhausted a
lot faster than it did for bre wild
because you know breath wild had so much
to
uncover because it was
new and of course we got the book which
also definitely helped to flesh out the
world
more and then we had the sequel
announcement too so there was the
potential of oh what else can we learn
which also in incentivized more breath
the wild
content like bre's lore Community was so
huge so
successful it literally made channels it
made my channel to to a certain extent
even though it was about 2 years no I
think more like three or four years
actually 3 years after breath wild I
think but I mean it's
still uh it still rode the same wave
just a little bit further at the end but
like hyro gamer Bandit games Nintendo
black crisis they all those channels did
not uh they owe so much to to bre the
wild like before that all all you had
was Celtic and even zeltic was still a
relatively small Creator at that time
Zelda or zeltic really did not take off
until after or right before or after
break the wild it's actually funny to
see how one game made so many channels
huge because I think before that you
only had
HMK game over
Jesse uh
Commonwealth vexi gaming which is still
one of my favorite Zelda YouTubers to
date ever God Rest her soul I think she
is it's a a tremendous loss to the
community because her videos were
just I think
probably is is probably what inspired my
own videos the most because I kind of
have try to have that same calm
atmosphere I don't do like the really
erratic editing I don't try to
be too fast about everything or have
flashy visuals I I kind of like that
almost archaeological slow paced editing
and explaining the story focusing in on
very small details that probably don't
even matter to the developers but they
do they matter to us like Vortex gaming
was really really really
good but that like those are the
veterans of of the Zelda Community all
almost everyone else that like big right
now they all came after bre wild or
during like right before during and and
after bre
wild and it was normal for most people
to just get a million views on almost
every Zelda video you made at that
time because there was so much to choose
from you know bre wild had you had the
Forgotten Temple you had your Cara
Citadel you had all the little tiny
Clues sprinkled throughout the world you
could
literally uh go through the whole world
and see how the Calamity unfolded just
by following the empty shells that the
broken down Guardians and all that stuff
and then of course like I said you have
the book that that came shortly after
that which also was just filled to the
brim with so much
lore like it was it was actually it was
a really special time for for Zelda
creators and I don't think we're going
to get that with uh with tears of the
Kingdom it's just I don't really see it
happening I think they're going to move
on and just focus on the next Zelda game
which I think is probably for the best
it's a sequel in the same world
anyway a lot of let's play channels soy
got big on bre toal too yeah exactly
yeah guys like pointcrow and uh Croton
and really good
stuff I just hope that for the next game
they you know kind of keep that in mind
a bit more because the people who love
the story while not the majority of
players they do kind of keep that hype
train alive because that those are the
people who are still going to be talking
about the
games like three years from now whereas
most of the other 20 million people who
played the game and just they're they're
already P like they they've probably
already passed the 10 games by now you
know they went from breath wild to
balers gate to whatever came after that
and they're just on their way to
different
things and at at most they will think
yeah Brew or tears the kingdom yeah that
was a that was a fun game it's a good
game I remember
that but but people like us who are
interested in more than just that first
playthrough we're the ones who kind of
keep keep the whole thing going you
know sometimes a minority even if it's a
minority it can have a huge huge impact
on the hype or the the general
atmosphere behind the
game actually I'm going to probably end
the live stream in just a few minutes
so there's not really a lot of reason to
keep playing for me at least not right
now I'm in a safe spot I have to make it
all the way back up to Mountain uh the
the mountain because I'm an
idiot and I didn't follow the objective
marker like some people told me I should
have but you know it is what it is oh
yeah you have to see hearth for for
first I I'll I'll quickly sail to Hearth
and then then I'm going to call it
quits I really want them to wait I
thought I saw something about sword
plate uh who said
that which one was
it oh yeah I want them to introduce
better Sword Play yeah I I
agree I agree it doesn't have to be like
Souls level of complicated but they they
could do something the same way they've
been innovating with uh new abilities
they could do something similar with the
combat cuz the the new abilities in this
game don't really have a whole lot of
combat uh well aside from maybe no not
not even recall
like it it doesn't have that
many uh implications for battle or
fights just stabby stabby and then back
flip is not enough they they do have to
kind of do something more with it at at
some
point it and again it doesn't have to be
as hard and difficult as Souls games but
I mean the souls games were inspired by
games like aine of time so it would only
make sense that Zelda does the same
thing now you know come full circle and
Zelda takes a few notes from games like
Elder ring for
example yeah dual wielding uh just
maybe go with a bit more magic a magic
build you don't have to go all the way
and
go to you know cleric mag uh cleric
magic and all that kind of stuff like it
doesn't have to become an ultimate game
but like the the the Ws for example in
this game they're kind of useless in
most
cases the the magic staffs or whatever
they
are they are very
underpowered yeah yeah they did have the
the the fuse elements at least that's
true you could experiment a little bit
more with your elemental weapons
and things like
that I'm going to steal all all your
wood oh and your construct
horns
uh did the objective marker change no it
did
not oh where's
Tulin you have to ask him about Tulin
first
learn anything
no okay
so yeah I'm going to call it
quits the bird just yeah his name is
Hearth it's a funny name for
bird what what's her name
again
Amali uh
yeah I'm gonna call it quits
because it's getting close to midnight
here sorry Perry Winkle I was just about
to leave but there will be more streams
uh this like next week I'm G to try to
do two streams one in the midweek and
then one more in the
weekend because I kind of want
to make up for the fact that I probably
won't be uploading any videos until the
beginning of February something like
that maybe even the second week of
February depending on how fast I can get
my script done of course
but I I kind of you know I like hanging
out with you guys I sometimes I forget
that streaming is fun because I'm so so
I'm kind of I tend to live in my own
little world sometimes for a while it's
just it's just how I I
work will I be streaming tomorrow no not
tomorrow tomorrow I have stuff to
do
uh but I will be streaming on
Wednesday or Thursday one of those two
and then again on Saturday or Sunday
next week also kind of depending on on
my schedule
because we also have to work on other
things of course also because the views
lately haven't been that amazing I'm
also doing a little bit more animation
work on the side just to make ends meet
you
know sometimes we have to do those
things oh thank you yeah the fireworks
video was very fun to work
on didn't get as much as many views as I
thought it would but you know it's under
five yeah I think it's under five
minutes so YouTube tends to prefer long
form videos unless it's shorts of course
shorts have really started to take off
on this platform it's crazy I've seen
shorts with like hundreds of millions of
views and it's just I don't know a dog
looking cute into the camera like man
the Tik Tock ification of of YouTube is
becoming
real yeah shorts I do agree I think it's
garbage
too it's it's speaking to those people
who have no attention span at all who
just want quick dopamine hits instead of
just watching a long form
interesting video
yeah the G gly Den uh video was fun to
make the the the
short but it was also very difficult
because I tend to overe explain a lot of
things and I want to mention as much as
possible and trying to fit that into one
minute is it's it was so it was
impossible I had to talk like so fast to
get everything across cover all the
basic Basics and even then I still wrote
so much I out of the out of the whole
script in
general like I I had to do a Snider's
cut of my my original script because I
ended up being like two and a half
minutes long I was like damn I thought
it was going to be way
shorter oh yeah well
Twisted slap
leer make a short where it's just a hen
dog looking cute into the camera oh
yeah let them do the the little twirly
thing people will eat that up for
sure but yeah to each their own I I just
don't like shorts myself at least I
don't like watching
them it's usually pretty brain that
stuff that's why I'm not on Tik Tok but
uh yeah anyway thanks to everyone for
dropping by it's been fun and uh I will
see you all next
week
[Music]
bye-bye
latter